that's why we won't have a mailing camp
because it's just mainly just
also i don't think people want to hear
some of the stuff you have to say
maitland i don't want to hear it i'm
glad these microphones are super cool
people people
dig up everything people don't know what
they're asking for we'd have to cut so
much [ __ ] if melinda starts thinking
about getting it awesome he's just a
[ __ ] normal employee
i'm just showing a camera interface
hello welcome to another episode of the
trash taste podcast i am bossman one
and i'm here with bossman two and three
here to get the dub hey
we're not the boys anymore we are boss
man we are the boss man
why did we not call that podcast welcome
to the boss man podcast
no no every week is a dub
uh how are you boys doing good i'm tired
as all
hell because you're in the middle of
moving right now aren't you
by the time this comes out i would have
finished moving yeah but um
yeah like literally tomorrow is the
moving day of me
so i have been just scrambling for the
past week just like clean i didn't real
you don't realize how much stuff you
have in your house until you start
cleaning it's always like that right
because i remember whenever i would move
like you start packing stuff stuff up
and you think to yourself it's gonna
take a day at most yeah and you pack up
like all the main stuff in like a day
you're like oh
i'm ninety percent of the way packed and
then for some reason all the like the
little [ __ ] that just like gets left
over
that takes like two days let me
introduce ourselves because you own
like i feel like 50 of the items you own
you never use
think about but you you think you need
them yeah yeah yeah you also never see
them either because they're like
either put in a closet or like you know
kind of out of sight somewhere right but
like you have like a colander
like you need a colander but like you
don't really think about it
until you you start using it or there
you're like what the [ __ ] do i do
we have like we have this like shaved
ice machine that uh i think i think
meline got it for us
but uh we we had it for like the last
summer because melia was like oh i want
to like come to your guys's place and
like
the girls can have like a kind of girls
like day and we can just make shaved ice
or whatever
never used it yeah that's oh we do okay
we used to once
we used it once and it's just this huge
brick of a thing that's just like
sitting in the kitchen i'm like okay
why is this here there's always that one
draw in every kitchen right that is just
the unused appliance drawer right where
it's just these appliances that people
give you as gifts
or that you think is going to be cool
when you host like that dinner party
that never happens
and then there's just these like random
appliances that just get put into this
drawer
and you forget you even have exactly
exactly we have like
forks use my hands
yeah well i i uh i got um this kind of
cleaning service thing because okay
one thing okay we're immediately going
to go on to this is one thing i hate
about japan
throwing away trash right okay and
especially the big trash
yeah right because like in australia
yeah yeah
just pick myself but um because like i
don't know about in the uk but in
australia we have like
this thing i think it happens once every
two or three months
uh it's called like council clean up day
so basically what we do is we take
huge appliances like couches beds you
know
drawers all that kind of stuff yeah and
we literally just throw it out
in front of the street like just onto
the street and
basically it's you know you throw it out
um people can kind of walk around and
just
you know grab stuff if they want like if
they think oh you know i can i think
two to three months it's like every two
to three months or something i've never
seen
this really in australia yeah it happens
i i don't know if maybe that's just like
the area yeah in the uk in the uk i
don't think there's enough space to just
throw
oh i think japan
we just throw stuff out and then big
garbage truck basically comes and
collects all the stuff that doesn't get
picked up after like a week
i think right um japan doesn't work like
that so like we had to throw away
our bed which is like a queen size bed
yeah uh a couch and like a couple of
tables
and like a sofa and stuff like that a
lot of big stuff but like you can't just
throw it out with the rest of the trash
you have to either you have to go to
your like
local council and be like i want to
throw this stuff away and they give you
these like tickets that you have to pay
for
yeah to basically be like all right i'm
throwing this out on this day and then
you throw it out onto this you have to
book it and tell them you have to book
it i need to tell the exact measurements
of the thing so yeah and plan out or
what i found out is you can just there's
just services out there that you can
just call up and be like i want to throw
all this crap away how much is it to get
rid of yeah yeah a little more expensive
than like the whole council thing but
so much easier i mean it's it's not a
price for me it's like
like we talked about last week it's just
getting the paperwork done yeah that
like
[ __ ] i'm scared of yeah exactly and
like i'm not even finished with the
[ __ ] paperwork too because we have to
do more after we move
yeah yeah because japan is just like a
never-ending sea of paperwork
but like i was like okay i'm getting rid
of this giant bed i'm getting rid of
this couch this table all these like big
appliances yeah
and i'm like okay well these are the big
things gone so you know maybe like
30 of my belongings probably gone it's
more like three
percent i feel like in like your bedroom
or office there's so many little things
you just never think about
especially my office yeah and my office
is so many little things i'm just like
i'm
i'm well first of all i'm looking
forward to like the moving company
coming in
and seeing like all of like my [ __ ]
skateboards and [ __ ] like that just
being like whoa
they'll be like oh is that is that a rem
eight one eighth scale
giving them a tour of your house you're
like yeah so this is this is the joker
it's a free office store
actually to be fair when the moving guy
first came in to like check to see what
we had
he walked into my office and he was like
whoa
otaku's dream he's like wow jesus this
guy's gonna [ __ ] collect
like the opposite happen where like i i
i only
use my tatami room to filming and i only
use it so i have a big tatami room that
i normally do the cosplay videos in
yeah yeah pretty bad so i never clean
them up after i just leave the cosplays
there until i do the next video and then
i clean it up
uh and then one time they didn't tell me
they were doing this but there was like
uh
they were checking like the fire alarms
in the building right and i was like
yeah sure come in come in
and he's going around my house he goes
into my office you know he looks
he's like oh i'm like yeah i like jojo
he just looked at me like i was [ __ ]
weird
and i was like all right thanks buddy
and then and then as he went to like my
tatami room i was like oh [ __ ] i just
remembered that all my [ __ ] was in there
and so like i i go in to check that he's
there and this man is just standing in
the middle of like my cosplay everywhere
this this stuff reached holding up
something to the fire alarm just looking
like look down don't look
don't look at anything and then after
this guy left
really awkwardly an hour later someone
else came along from the same company in
the building and did the exact same
thing right yeah and i was like wait why
am i being checked twice oh he's like a
spot man
i don't know i was really just gonna
make sure my friend got it right you
know he's like yo i heard this free
cosplay wasn't that
okay and then i had the exact same
interaction again where i was like oh
yeah sorry about the mess in this room
by the way i like jojo
by the way i also like jojo
[ __ ] weirdo but luckily like we yeah
like as i said i'm pretty sure i
mentioned in the previous podcast
episode
we gotta service that where they just do
all the packing yeah yeah my god i
cannot imagine
if i had to do that all myself i just
kind of realized what
i'm gonna have to go through when we
move um because
my room's gonna be fine um but then i
got sydney's room yeah
which the amount of [ __ ] [ __ ] up
[ __ ] in sydney
so be careful that's the [ __ ] of the
round that looks expensive
so i remember i remember this one time
we we had to get like our doorbell fix
right
so we we thought we thought our house
was pretty clean basically whenever
someone needs to come in to check
our house at all we just make sure like
sydney's room is just [ __ ] locked off
it's it's it's like a quarantine section
you know
you put the [ __ ] biohazard sign on
the door just to make sure no one gets
in
right but radioactive yeah yeah so so
how we learned our lesson was we had our
door
we had our doorbell fixed and of course
sydney's room was like cordoned off
but we forget that sometimes sydney just
has
[ __ ] lying about the house right and i
guess we've just become so desensitized
to some of the stuff she reviews my my
fiance reviews a lot of lewd stuff
that's
that's that's her channel so we just had
like a bunch of figures
that were just left in the living room
with just like their tits out right
living room
so so this guy this guy just comes in
right and um
the the doorbell's like right next to
the kitchen and also we have a shelf
right next to the kitchen
which just has two lewd completely naked
figures just right next to where the
doorbell is he takes a look at
looks at the figures looks at sydney and
just doesn't make eye contact with
sydney ever again
is it he's got like hentai here
just like he's covering his eyes
sweating
yeah that was probably the longest
[ __ ] hour he had to like enjoy his
life
when he was just finished i love how he
immediately looked at sydney like most
like you wouldn't think that like you're
looking like gone right being like this
[ __ ] right
he's like leaving his loose [ __ ] out no
immediately he went to sydney he's like
god i wish that was me
i wish my wife would let me put my my
dirty fingers in god
yeah it's the one time whenever someone
comes around and i'm just like yo this
these loose stuff that's that's not me
guys guys that's not me it's just my
partner you're just like silently yeah
yeah
no no seriously seriously it's my
partner this time
yeah i i mean i had to like because i
have like quite a few like dozens and
stuff like that in my bookshelf as well
so i was like
i'll pack these away before i uh because
like i'm with these guys for like
a couple of days yeah like i don't want
like an awkward experience for a couple
of days
as they like sift through my dozens
being like so what's the fragile stuff
and what's not the fragile stuff
but um yeah so like because of that i
have just
been so incredibly busy i haven't been
able to like sit down
like play any games i mean [ __ ] pokemon
snap came out like a few days ago
haven't been able to like download that
[ __ ] at all you're not ahead on videos
anymore are you which is just like
i heard that about joey and i'm just
like what what is going on dude
me i think well i mean i think this
comes at end of may right but
like the slowest month i've ever had
like i think my next video is not coming
out for like 12 days or something i'm
like oh my god my career is over dude
daily god man it's just like the the
like the signs the apocalypse is
happening yeah
[ __ ] sky is falling and joey is not
ahead on video exactly that's how i know
the end of the that's how i know that
i'm so not ahead that i'm falling behind
i'm falling and i can't get up
i missed an upload as well and it like
killed me i like apologized
on my youtube page and people were like
you don't have to apologize yeah i'm
like no i'm like no i do
i do it's not i'm not apologizing for
you i'm apologizing to me
yeah yeah because that's the thing right
it's like like 12 days
to the average youtube viewer is like
whatever
like there's no difference between seven
days between videos and like two weeks
between
upload yeah but to the person who makes
it it's like
oh no it's all i think about you know
this is damn videos
you know this is the first time in my
career where i've been like a head-on
video so i'm just like damn i have some
free time
uploads more than joey
oh my god oh yeah no yeah maybe maybe
one day maybe one day maybe one
i'll be back i'll be back when come on
let's do it
wait until god discovers five nights at
freddy's guys
so yeah i mean now that [ __ ]
lockdown's been
happening again i guess we can call up
the 17th
time for the 17th time i don't know
lockdown in japan has been weird right
it's a rollercoaster it goes like the
cases go up they announce a chilly
lockdown that's like two more rules
added
the case is good now and then and then
they go back up again when they let go
of restrictions
and then this is happening like the wall
the fourth time now yeah so we're just
doing the same [ __ ] over and over again
but this lockdown is the shortest ever
it's only two weeks or something yeah i
think they're like
what's gonna change in two weeks i think
they literally just wanted to be like oh
golden week's happening
uh let's let's let's have it not happen
meanwhile i'll explain
everybody to the the viewers who don't
know yeah so golden week is this week uh
during the first week of may
uh we're as we're recording this we're
in the middle of it right now where it's
basically just
a bunch of public holidays back to back
to back to back-to-back
so i think yeah so basically people just
get
a week off do you know how i remember
golden week it was the one week of the
year aside from like new year's where
manga
mangakaz would take a break from that
weekend so i'm just like oh one piece is
on break
what the [ __ ] golden week thank god
finally
everything's on fire i didn't get one
piece this week
that's the only reason i knew of golden
week before moving to japan yeah exactly
well because like i think you know japan
needs golden week because yeah japan's
one of the few countries that works on
christmas
you know like christmas is just like i
think everywhere else christmas is like
a public holiday or at least like
in australia yeah well yeah like in
australia like you know
it's like the second half of december
until maybe the first week of
january like three weeks it's just full
on holiday christmas here is just
valentine's day 2.0
yeah basically it is it really is [ __ ]
yeah but they were just like
i don't have a cup i don't have a
partner finna work
it's either you're on a date or you are
working on
something yeah exactly so i guess like
you know to japan they need
golden week because it's the one time
where they're almost forced to
take the week off yeah because otherwise
they get i mean you know people still
are just like no [ __ ] it it's still
working week for me but yeah yeah my
whole favorite thing of uh
all the japanese governments lockdowns
is that they did in the
in like during the whole pandemic the
government
thought of this amazing idea called go
to travel
she's just like oh yeah this is just the
funniest this is the funniest [ __ ]
thing
so japanese government they were losing
a lot of money obviously from tourism
that they wouldn't they weren't getting
so in the middle of like the pandemic
this is like months ago it's before this
is last year it was during the first
lockdown wasn't it yeah yeah they were
like guys
we're losing too much money in our
travel economy we put some money back
into it what we're gonna do is guys
we're gonna give you
30 off everything and we're gonna pay
you money to go
travel we'll give you 200 bucks to spend
depending on how much you spend
and uh yeah you get coupons at your yeah
yeah yeah so yeah
they were like oh yes so like it's a
lockdown but also if you travel
thirty percent discount hey there's some
money to spend go treat yourself
king but don't leave the house though
but don't leave like yeah and then like
they realized it was like a colossal
mistake like a month later when
the cases went up i [ __ ] up because
everyone's of course everyone's gonna
travel
exactly you're paying me to travel and
you don't want me to travel
like if you went to like a five-star
hotel that's like a thousand bucks it
would go down to like 600 and then you'd
be given like 300 bucks to spend and
it's like
who isn't gonna do that like if you have
disposable income it's like anyone is
gonna do that it's like dangling a
carrot in front of a horse and telling
the horse not to run
he's like don't don't i'm finna try to
be responsible yeah
japanese governor making me act up you
know what i mean i i want you know
i was like well [ __ ] i'm going hokkaido
and of course everyone
everyone abused the [ __ ] out of that
system right everyone went traveling
yeah because
it was like why wouldn't i i went to
like four different places so i was like
i'm obviously not because like literally
everybody is going right so it's like
what's the point what's the point of not
going it was the most confusing period
ever because they were like don't travel
but please travel
please please travel we need it for you
and then and then they shut it down like
after
like a month yeah yeah of course it was
it was a colossal mistake yeah i mean if
i went to hokkaido because i was like
[ __ ] yeah
you know i didn't interact with anyone
but i
and it was because it was because you
guys kept talking about hokkaido and i
was like okay
i think it's my time to go hokkaido as
well waited for lockdown to end and i'm
just like
damn this is they they weren't joking
around
[ __ ] hokkaido exactly exactly in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere no one's there
it's like great
yeah it's peaceful it's fantastic it was
just the dumbest thing ever because if
they
just kept like this is the whole thing
that the japanese governments are doing
where they just kind of haven't really
committed to anything
yeah they haven't really told you not to
do anything i think i very wish you were
i think that's the thing every every
restriction they've given it seems very
half-assed from my like from my
perspective
no it's it's not it's not been like
we've never been fully open
but we've also never been fully closed
either like they've never said you can't
travel around they they're the worst
thing or if anything they reward you for
it
yeah yeah yeah and then no and then they
they also said like oh yeah you know
restaurants please close at eight
you know like suddenly for some reason
people are just you know magically stop
getting infected before right yeah i
mean this new lockdown there were like
restaurants can't serve alcohol anymore
right yeah and i'm just like
so i'm still allowed to go to the right
yeah yeah yeah
but i just can't drink beer like it's
it's generous to even call it like half
measures it's like
you know like a quarter of measures yeah
is what they do and
you know i don't know i don't really
care about the whole politics at all but
i wish they would just decide what they
wanted well that's the problem isn't it
is that like unlike a lot of countries
the japanese
japanese law they can't force
establishments to close down yeah like a
lot of other countries
and so they're like they're like okay so
we can't force you to close down but we
we we advise you to not serve alcohol to
not
to close after eight but there's but
there's also like
from what i heard there's like a penalty
for like establishments that
don't follow those rules but if you get
you've got to find a [ __ ] ton of money
yeah the restaurants that make so much
money well
that's the thing i would just pay the
bills the penalty is so low that there
are a lot of restaurants out there
especially in like in a tokyo that are
just like
all paid for some of like the biggest
restaurants i think just pay the fine
yeah they pay the finances
they make more off of the money that
they yeah yeah yeah and also they were
like
the biggest that was like not even the
fine it was like we'll put you on a list
of companies that stayed open and
obviously just a lot of japanese people
that's like that's pretty like [ __ ]
we've got [ __ ] we're gonna be on the
list
yeah but then for some of them they were
like i'll [ __ ] give a [ __ ] about it
it's like getting on the naughty list on
santa right yeah yeah yeah
it's like oh no that's so so dumb yeah
so dumb
that's the thing it would have this
would have been at least australia and
new zealand
like totally locked down yeah like new
zealand were like nah yeah yeah in
australia no one could do anything
australia locked down for like nine
months
yeah yeah and like people couldn't go
outside for more than an hour a day
and like yeah all restaurants were
closed all that kind of stuff and like
yeah and then when in sydney at least we
got one
case and the entire city went into
lockdown for like a month
meanwhile japan is like a thousand cases
don't drink at restaurants
it's like cool thanks yeah but i mean
it's it'll be interesting to see
what happens in this next year because
every every other country seems to be
getting their vaccines and we are
still like we're probably not going to
be able to get our vaccines this year if
we stay in japan
it's right looking more and more likely
but i mean you know there's like i know
of a few of my american friends who are
here who are just probably just going to
like bite the bullet and just go back to
america
this sometime this year to just go get
the whole thing yeah everyone like my
age in america is already getting it
yeah yeah yeah exactly in the uk as well
right yeah
uk as well yeah it's like being a kid
again when they always got the games
before you
[ __ ] man i'm like why are you all
getting the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] it's
reversed now like yeah it's the last one
exactly like japan was always the first
now you're the last i
feel like i've been lied to but like are
you guys gonna do it
i'm probably gonna do it i mean i don't
blame you i'll [ __ ] do it like if i
was an american or like
or from the uk i would absolutely it's
twofold for me right because i i want to
go back to the uk i want to go back to
uk yeah my friends toast goddamn it
you know it's been like this is i think
this is the longest i've been from like
seeing my family
yeah see my friends yeah so i'm just
like that's that
that and the vaccine if i can get
everything done in one trip then that's
yeah i'm gonna take like a month and a
half off
japan and just go do the things that i
want
i need to do for my health and also
catch up to all the things like
toast in it just want to have it it's
just [ __ ] my friends just beans
there's no heinz beans here what the
[ __ ] am i supposed to do like
see the problem was [ __ ] depressing
i'm sorry i crave it i don't think
there's a more depressing sight than
just
beans and toast by itself i'm sorry this
is a separate other brand
tastes good as a brit like seeing the
sight of just like beans on toast as
like a [ __ ]
breakfast dinner whatever that's
fantastic see i feel that way but
like two or three times a year i just
wake up and i'm like
[ __ ] go for some beans right now
baked beans
baked beans heinz great source of
protein as well
yeah like what's not to like [ __ ] me up
beans are magical they're like [ __ ]
fantastic make me fall like a
[ __ ] but who cares still good
who cares i like that you know it feels
like you're being cleansed
it's like detoxing but like that's the
problem right it's like at least you
guys and like all my american friends
have
you know a choice to do that right yeah
go back it's you know doubly like get it
back
like australia apparently made it
illegal to return if you're from india
right if you're yeah oh really
i think a lot of legal like
well that's the problem right is that
like i can't do the same for australia
because we're in no rush to get the
vaccine because no one's had covert for
the past four months yeah so like not
even my grandma who's like
92 this year has gotten it yet yeah it's
like
late maybe like you got you guys are
isolated as [ __ ] it's hard enough to get
in your country as it is
exactly yeah i mean it makes sense right
but like you know that's why australia's
done so well
and same with new zealand but that's
what like the whole world goes through
like the [ __ ] apocalypse australia is
just gonna be australian new zealand are
gonna be like
two remaining countries exactly right
nothing goes in nothing comes out
man seeing the whole like uh like the
whole joe rogan controversy about all
the like vaccines and stuff
yeah it's it's so frustrating that like
it's literally
been the only thing anyone can talk
about for the past like year and a half
is covered in all this [ __ ] yeah but
it's also like saying that you can't
talk about because everyone's [ __ ]
turned it into a political thing
yeah where it's just like i just i just
want to eat baked beans i just don't
want to die
i just i just don't want to be ill and i
don't want to get other people
ill yeah i didn't i didn't know it's
become like a thing like that
like even now talking about it i feel
like [ __ ] there's probably like some
[ __ ]
[ __ ] in the comments who are like
annoyed about it i was talking about i
just want to kiss my homies good night
man
exactly come on man let me kiss my
homies [ __ ] hell yeah
i just want to eat some [ __ ] baked
beans watch cars 2 in the theater you
know just
well i mean what wasn't it like the uk
recently i think like couple of days ago
just
had their first muscle mask mask-less
concert it was like 5 000 people at a
concert or something and there were none
of them wearing musk because they were
all vaccinated i'm not sure about
melin can you like check i'm pretty sure
i saw that this morning
but like i'm not surprised either
because the uk has been i mean the us
and the uk have been so [ __ ] good
with their vaccines i loved how uh
in the uk when they literally were like
okay guys i think you can
maybe go out for drinks now yeah like
the first day
london was like rammed and it was just
children of course it would be
and they were like here we waited like
10 years for this we're going to go to
the pinewood jerry
just like oh my god exactly go i can't i
can't imagine how weather spoons was
going to be like
as soon as i opened up oh my god i do
miss a good weather spoons actually
you know the government could tell like
if britain had to fight in like another
war
you know and the government was like
please fight please fight for us and
they'd be like nah nah they're like
pubs will be open if you fight they'll
be like where are we fighting where are
we fighting
i don't know what it is about pubs and
british people but like it turns them
into something it's
like ferocious like when pubs come into
the equation yeah they become like
different people yeah they're like
you suddenly become more passionate yeah
i i feel like people
in britain weren't taking like the
pandemic seriously until pub started
closing down yeah and that's that's like
the real [ __ ]
of the world they're like i sleep i
can't go to school or work whatever
whatever
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] there's a
political agenda
how dare they close the polls that's
that's the exact moment it got political
i can't believe these politicians have
done this
my arm hurts tell me if the pendulum
weren't playing
you know i know british come on that's a
[ __ ] lie there's no way come on there
is no [ __ ] way
the amount of clubs of like 16 and 17
year olds like the fake
ids come on there's people are faking
like their passport that's 100
exactly passports or whatever like the
[ __ ] bouncers give a [ __ ]
yeah kidding me sure you could hand a
[ __ ] mcdonald's like 10 coffee card
to them as an idea they'd let you
[ __ ] in the club in the uk to be fair
to be fair though if any country is
probably going to do like a fully normal
concert first it's going to be the us of
the uk with how they're going
yeah i might assume whether they should
yeah when they shoot is a different
question but i mean from what i've heard
from like like
third-party information from all my
mates back there it's the one thing that
we've been doing well about
about the uh pandemic which is the
vaccine response right
which is just it kind of makes sense we
[ __ ] bought them all up
[ __ ] you other countries this is our
first world country money yeah
give us that it's pretty tragic though
it's just like us uk bought them all and
then no one else gets it yeah exactly
[Music]
it's pretty tragic really yeah you know
because you get it from the inside of
the club you're like yeah we're doing
great and then yeah
you see well yeah of course how's the
rest of the world doing
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah right it's pretty
tragic
money talks exactly exactly but uh where
have you guys been what you guys been
doing in the meantime you guys been
traveling around
you've been doing anything interesting
well before lockdown before lockdown
from when we could travel
in the little bits that we could um we
recently just went camping
i know i couldn't come i know the
yeah i wanted to come camping with you
yeah so me and like
four of our friends went camping in the
mountains of shizuoka yeah
it was my first experience camping in
japan and uh
definitely was a very different
experience if you've never been camping
before
i recommend you go camping in japan
because it is like
mario kart baby mode camping yeah it
really is
you roughly describe it to me but you're
saying there's like electricity okay
okay so
so let me tell you about this right so
um i've only been camping i think once
or twice else in my life
okay so wait okay with one question did
you get like a lot
what's that like a square yeah yeah yeah
we
so my only other experience camping it's
been just like in the middle of the
[ __ ] fields like i
i went on like a trip in colorado where
we just like rode horses for eight hours
and we camped literally in the middle of
like the woods in colorado
that was like that was what i thought it
was gonna be [ __ ] fantastic it was
[ __ ] great
i thought it was gonna be something
similar yeah so uh so
i'm not that experienced camping so i
was i asked i asked the boys so what
should i be bringing
right and they they give me the usual or
sleeping bags
um you know tents um warm clothes and
everything and also like
a power bank to charge your phone so i
came in with the
expectations of i need to buy a big
[ __ ] power bank because we're not
gonna have any power there
yeah yeah we can't beat for like two
days yeah yeah this episode is sponsored
by boxer
boys get those disgusting american chips
out of here because this episode is
sponsored by
bok su an authentic japanese snack bar
subscription that sends you small
delicious treats from japan this month's
boxer is kicking off
summer with a tropical travels themed
box these snacks bring you flavors from
down south in kyushu
and okinawa with exotic flavors like
native citrus and local seasonings now
if that doesn't sound fancy i don't know
what does what have we got in the box
god
well let me tell you we've got shima
togodashi rice crackers and peanuts
marui chinsko kobusu nutsable cookie and
nailed it but guys wait there's more
this month's snack tea pairing is higa
granny's san pinchar jasmine tea
these aren't like their competitors box
who partners with japanese artisanal
makers to bring you authentic flavors we
said it before
and we're gonna say it again this is
cross-cultural pollination
like never before so use our link and
code trash test 10 in the description to
get 10 off
your own box suit now repeat customers
get a theme box
every month back to the episode so
friend he has this thing called like the
omni charge i can't remember the full
name
but that it was it looked like a [ __ ]
battle station i remember
yeah yeah but like it was way bigger
than any of the portable chargers i've
ever seen
and also like what sold me was that it
had its own plug so you can plug like
so you can you can plus the adapter yes
you can plug an actual like
power adapter to it right so i was like
i want something like that for a camping
trip
right so i said oh what's this thing
called so
he calls he says it's the omnicharger so
i google it on amazon and unfortunately
they're not selling on amazon anymore
so i go to like the first link that's
recommended
for like that search and here's the
thing about amazon
is that you see a charger right
there's nothing to like quantify how
how big this charger is right just from
the image yeah yeah yeah
that's not with dimensions but i mean
you might not look at them yeah
sometimes it's like buried in a wall of
like text yeah yeah
it's buried in a wall of text so i just
see this block right and i'm just like
it's probably around the same i mean
it's recommended from me searching the
omni charger
so he's probably about the same size
right he's probably around the same size
like thinking back like being like an
electronic an electrical ex-electronic
and electrical engineer
we've got a masters i should have seen
like the amount of like charge it holds
but i didn't look about the amount of
charge it holds i just i just i was just
like
on like um [ __ ] autopilot mode i'm
just like yeah that looks good
buy that okay so wait a few days from
all my camping equipment that i bought
um and this [ __ ] massive package like
um
i wish you brought it with you today i
wish i did i wish i did the smashes pack
this massive package gets delivered to
my door
i'm and i'm all right uh don't it
everything's like boxed up so i don't
know what everything is
so the first thing i pick up it's
[ __ ] heavy it's this [ __ ] brick
and my first thought was
oh no have i bought like a sleeping bag
that's just like 10 times heavier than i
needed it you're right
and so i start unboxing it and i see
this [ __ ] brick just in my hands
right
and i'm just like what the [ __ ] is this
what i've
i don't remember buying anything this
heavy yeah turn it around
and it's the [ __ ] charger and i'm
like no wait this must be how big is it
this must be a mistake um so joey joey
has a photo
it's on screen right now the photo of
this brick that i got i turn it around
i look at like the appliances that i can
power and it's just like okay so this
can power
phones it can you know charge tablets
and then it says you can charge laptops
it can power a [ __ ] mini fridge
and i'm just like you can power a mini
fridge a microwave and i'm just like
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] have i bought
this this thing he bought it literally
is like oh i found it
so this is like a [ __ ] brick that i
bought two routers strapped together
yeah yeah
and i'm just like what the [ __ ] mac mini
i don't know what i'm gonna be able to
do with this because like
i can't take that on a plane because
like if i take it on a plane
the tsa probably thinks i'm gonna bomb
the [ __ ] plane
get [ __ ] arrested like i'm probably
gonna be on the [ __ ] isis list if i
take us from a plane
jesus christ so i can't even so i'm just
thinking to myself all right
i've made guys i've made a mistake
but it's okay because at least i can use
it on this camping trip
so like i like this massive [ __ ]
brick in my
suitcase or in my bag sorry which is
probably like
like by itself the heaviest single
object in my bag for a camping trip
yeah um and so we get to this campsite
and
you know we get we get a lot and we
start unpacking everything
and i see this metal box right i see
these metal box and i was just like
what the [ __ ] is that metal box my first
thought was oh it's probably like a safe
they provided right because
you know i hear about some american
campsites something like bear safes or
something so
i was thinking i might be a safe or
something um
and so i was like navi what's that and
he's just like
just way gone let me show you he opens
it up and it's a [ __ ] power outlet
but there's two power hours sticking out
like that i'm just like
yes camping with my power up yeah right
and i'm just like
so wait there's literally no [ __ ]
reason for me to buy this [ __ ] brick
and lug this around
i can't take it anywhere can't take it
on the plane and apparently it's useful
and it's
apparently it's useless for a camping
trip what the [ __ ] do i need this for
you literally
i looked at that thing and i'm like
that's what people use for like
emergencies
like when like your house is flooded and
you have no electricity and like this is
the thing
yeah i'm just like if japan syncs ever
happens
i'm [ __ ] sorted man you are like the
top of the hierarchy like people have
been
fighting the first night he like charged
his phone
well he was like i might as well use
this [ __ ] thing yeah so he charged
his phone right it was like a hundred
percent
next morning phone is fully charged 97
he's three percent of his charge his
power is fine i'm like
this thing could last you like literally
like two months yeah i i literally
insane
i literally bought it just so i could
recharge my phone during during the
duration
like ventilation like yeah yeah yeah
yeah i
knew he was like [ __ ] way too
overkill when i opened it up had a vent
that had like a fan
turned on he turned it on and it
literally started going
[Music]
i'm like this way yeah so three percent
power of the [ __ ] fan probably yeah
but he charged your [ __ ] phone it was
so funny
yeah but like i've been camping quite a
bit in australia like my dad and i used
to go having all the [ __ ] i don't
want to [ __ ] counter a power outlet
with the [ __ ] yeah exactly but like
i i realized okay japan does not know
how to go through camping
because like it really is yeah it really
is baby mode on mario
so we we saw someone like so like we had
like some relatively small tents right
neighbors yeah we had neighbors yeah
that's that's the thing that really put
me off because i thought we
it was but it was one lot of part b so
there was social distancing
it was one lot of part it was social
distancing
[ __ ] yeah probably one thing i one
thing i learned about
ten is that it's just not noise proof at
all i can hear [ __ ] everything
literally i remember we were sleeping
and i just i could hear like the other
tent [ __ ] farting
in the background and i'm just like okay
who was that was that you nabi okay
whatever
but like some of these tents that these
people bought they weren't [ __ ] tense
so some of our neighbors right um one
one lots like
like two lots down from us they they
start unpacking this ten
right and then they this tent has
[ __ ] compartments right
and then not only that you you i
remember walking past they had an
entrance
right they had an entrance that had
lights on the entrance
okay and like fairy lights and this tent
had like
two [ __ ] bedrooms a living room oh my
god my parents
didn't like that yeah and has that even
a tent though yeah it's like a family
time it's just a pop-up apartment
yeah but it's like a family tent i'm
just i'm just like this isn't a ten this
is a two ldk bro though like jesus tents
are a [ __ ] nightmare
yeah well but that's the thing right
it's like i get it if it was a family
but this was a couple this is a couple
yeah that's ridiculous yeah yeah
unlike that test that's because you're a
japanese couple so naturally you're not
gonna sleep in the same bag
of course i was i was getting to that
because this this like this tent had
carpet
had shelves and i'm just like might as
well just like bring a [ __ ] caravan
at this point we'd take that but we
stayed for like three weeks
that makes sense if it's three weeks
they stayed for a single night and like
of course okay so here's like the single
night yeah
they they came with us and they left
them so so here's the premium japanese
couple experience that i saw right so we
walked past this tent
right and of course this japanese couple
you know
obviously very intimate japanese couple
to be going on a camping trip by
themselves together
very intimate so the peak japanese
couple experience was
seeing the guy next to his car on a
[ __ ] gamer chair or something
and then seeing the girl on the other
side of this massive tent
on a hammock both of them by themselves
not interacting
premium japanese couple experience i
mean isn't that love
knowing when to ignore each other yeah
that's love no i i mean i say it's a
free room japanese couple experience
because
the amount of times like we've gone to
like onsens or ryokans or something and
like
it's just like us the boys and we're
just surrounded by japanese couples they
don't talk to each other not talking to
them
just not interacting with each other
couples that social distance together
stay together you know
they're just social distancing yeah yeah
but like one one part i couldn't [ __ ]
believe was um
with wood fire right so you had to like
go to oh i mean they had the option to
go to like the
the reception quote unquote where you
could buy
pre-cut wood fire yeah that's normally
how it is right yeah like so off
yeah cause they don't want you just
[ __ ] picking [ __ ] up around the area
right but like but like the thing is i
mean that's what we can that's what we
did
because each bundle was like 500 yen
right like maybe for like a bundle
it wasn't it wasn't about the price it
wasn't about the price
because like this wood because it's like
pre-cut and clean and dry
yeah this thing burns through like so
[ __ ] quickly i'm like
we're here for the entire day we want
this fire to keep going the entire day
right yeah this thing
is not going to last us the entire day
yeah so i just said [ __ ] it
and i just like went out into the bush
and just grabbed some wood and
then nabi had a hatchet and i'm like
give me that [ __ ] just [ __ ] started
like
deforesting
i didn't cut down any trees yeah yeah so
to emphasize we didn't cut off any trees
we just cut off like some some branches
that had fallen down we cut the logs
into like sizeable pieces yeah yeah and
brought them back to our campsite
because that that to me is the camping
experience right we're out in the
wilderness
we're like yeah you're like out here in
like like a [ __ ] swimming pool
treating it like bear grylls
[Music]
that's the thing it's like i don't know
we wanted to make the most out of it
honestly
because it's like otherwise we would
have to spend like 100 bucks for
firewood i'm like
[ __ ] that i don't know i mean it's not
about a hundred bucks of firewood
because it's just not about the money
joey
it's about the experience it's about the
experience exactly
i had so i the most amount of fun i had
was going out into the bush
picking up some like dead trees and just
bringing it back and just chopping the
[ __ ] out of it that was the most fun i'd
be so [ __ ]
bored if i turned up and it should like
i got like 10 neighbors we got a power
outlet yeah
and it's like pre-packages like here you
go here's all the things you need go go
have fun
go [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] micro transactions
with your camping experience man
probably like bring your food if you
want to i know i know some camping trips
actually bring you meat
like on the grill if you want if you
want to have food i like to stay at a
hotel the best part about camping right
is when you all turn up right and then
your one mate is like voice
i brought bacon and everyone's like yes
let's go
exactly perishable foods what an idiot
but it works
like i mean in the uk you can just
there's a little place you can just kind
of ask them you're like hey can i camp
on your land they were like yeah sure
yeah yeah
stuff like that there's a lot of places
where you can camp like i mean australia
there's like you know designated camping
areas but like
it's first come first so if something if
it's full then [ __ ] off
that in japan or is it all just
regulated it's all regulated yeah
yeah it's i mean it was fine for
the experience it was but i definitely
preferred the camping experience i had
in other countries because
it just it just kind of didn't feel like
camping you know i mean there was that
other couple next to us that brought a
[ __ ] tv
oh yeah honestly honestly i'd do it i'd
do it too and they're like playing smash
bros or whatever the [ __ ] was i'm like
hell yeah just like
why are you even camping dude i mean if
you've got a [ __ ] plug why not bring
the 15 i guess so yeah
i guess i'll bring the 50-inch yeah i
guess like
i was like you think that these guys
have been like permanently living there
with how much [ __ ] they have too far i
mean
i'd be tempted to bring like you can get
those like really shitty uh like
19-inch battery-powered uh monitors yeah
yeah yeah
you know but there is nothing the thing
is is like because i've you know because
i've had a pretty [ __ ] stressful week
because of the whole move thing
but so it's just so nice to just just
sit down
and look at a fire for 12 hours and
literally drink and talk about nothing
yeah it was the best [ __ ] experience
i've had
that is the best part yeah yeah because
like because who set up the tents
um yeah did you really did you all did
you really
yeah we all did we all did really
because most of the time it's we all
didn't it's like i watched
our tents really weren't that
complicated really right because it was
r10 was literally just like a triangle
one of one of those [ __ ] yeah it
wasn't it wasn't a [ __ ] inflatable
apartment
it wasn't it wasn't a two-bedroom
apartment yeah when i was uh when i was
like 15
i had the ones where you like you
[ __ ] throw it in the air and yeah
yeah like like nabi had one of those as
well but like our past
though yeah yeah ours was a bit more
complicated and we still somehow [ __ ]
it up
um because so our 10 was like it's it's
it's like not
pre i mean it kind of is pre-built but
we kind of have to like
strengthen the uh the supports what what
about the support beams that come
with them right so what are they called
like the destruction
yeah the poles the bone structure i
don't [ __ ] know it's not holes just
[ __ ] poles
it's not it wasn't a pole because it was
like part of the tent right so this tent
came with like support beams
that like supported the structure right
and it was almost [ __ ] poles it's
baby mode like i said baby mo baby moten
mode we did we literally didn't have to
do anything we just had to like [ __ ]
we well we thought we didn't have to do
anything right
because it all kind of like unfolded and
we like put it up we just we
all we had to do is like put the pegs
down we thought great job done
uh we didn't know it was job done
because when we were trying to sleep
when we when when we were when me and
joey were trying to sleep
just kept caving in right because it was
also
windy it was it was a windy yeah
insanely it was a windy ass night so
every like [ __ ] hour
i'd get woken up by this ten just caving
in and i just have to like bring the
support pole
up again i'm just like oh that's a
[ __ ] sake and i i i
i could hear joey was like having
trouble sleeping as well
and it was not sleep at all and it was
only when we were packing up
that we took the cover off and i was
just like at the top of the support beam
there was this label that said push i
was like
why does this label say push and i push
it down
and i just hear click and everything is
like
a solid aspect like transformers
i just hear this click and i was like
what was that click and then i tried to
like push
push in the support beams like the
manual or anything no no
no clearly clearly we should have i mean
it was a tense i'll just give it a click
quickly well because like i'm not used
to tense like that i'm used to the ones
where you have to like kind of connect
all the poles together and do it
yourself right so i'd so i was like oh
cool this is
who bought the tents oh naby dude so i
was like oh i've never seen this kind of
tent but it seems
easy enough it literally just some
reason whenever you [ __ ] do your
friend's tent
it's like the biggest piece of [ __ ] ever
it's like it's like your tent pristine
brand new yeah well your friend's tent
is literally like falling apart the
poles don't [ __ ] connect they're
rusty as [ __ ] it's like
what do you do what do you do to this
tent how did you put it in this bad
condition
i don't know yeah that but like that
night it was so
[ __ ] windy i mean the day before it
was so [ __ ] raining that
we were just like we're not we're not
camping out there it's like a torrential
thunderstorm out
yeah so we're just gonna [ __ ] we just
went to like a nearby dyokon but
the next day though when we actually
went camping was [ __ ] great yeah it
was
it was a great experience i remember
argued the next day it was aki was like
so what did you guys talk about and i
just sat there i was like it doesn't
matter what you [ __ ] what did i talk
about what
what's what's talked about camping stays
in canada yeah exactly
it was clearly so unimportant that it
didn't even retain in my memory
so all i remember is oh fire burn that's
all i remember from that camping trip i
just
gave my instincts come out i remember
trying to start a fire for like a full
hour
because like nabi bought these flints
i'm just like
guys guys we've got a power outlet like
in a bear grill
let's get a [ __ ] outlet like no and
edo for the entire time was standing
there with a blowtorch it was like
really when you are gone [ __ ] creme
brulee on my campsite what's going on so
there's just me like huddled around
these like this [ __ ] mosque trying to
set that on fire
i'm like i try i try setting like so
many like i try like getting some
youtube tutorials out
i tried this for like a [ __ ]
torrential range the day before so all
the wood's gonna be working and
meanwhile i'm just like sitting there on
like my gaming channel just playing
firestarter
it's like oh you got it you gotta make
it oh my god
but it was i just wanted to play bear
grylls it was like so it was
almost scary how enthusiastic gantt was
to start a fire
he was just like you know like because
like we gotta
make it sound like a [ __ ] i'm a
[ __ ] casual artist so we got that we
got it
we got there right and we're like all
right let's figure out what we're gonna
do all right we gotta set up a tent you
know blah blah blah alright everybody
help get all the stuff out and god's
just kind of standing there like
i just can't wait to start a fire
oh my god that's that's how people
become arsenal come on come on
let's let's let's not pretend that the
start of a camping trip is always
when you are able to first start of
course
that's how you know the camping trip has
been i knew i knew from
i knew from how enthusiastic yeah
i knew from how enthusiastic god was to
start the fire i was like
if i let this man start a fire he's not
going to do anything else
he's going to stay next to that fire
fueling that [ __ ] for like 12 hours
who the [ __ ] enjoys building a tent like
no
no no one he actually enjoys building a
tent it's fiddly as [ __ ]
after time you're trying to figure out
how the instruction manuals work
because they're like you mean the
instruction manual we didn't read yeah
exactly right because it's a [ __ ]
pain in the ass you're trying to figure
out
like has somehow somehow they've picked
the images that make it like the least
legible and like the least
understandable to like figure out how to
like build this
sounds like you you took the monkey
brain on the trip yeah i didn't need to
come
there was already monkey bro gant was
very monkey brain around that fire like
he was like i i i feed him
i was single-handedly fueling that fire
for like 12 hours
this this fire went on for like 12 hours
and i was the one like fueling it every
time yeah
it's like i don't have to do anything
i'm just god's just like assistant right
here just like fueling up
we need to look for like an actual place
where we can camp with like
legit like legit i don't know
outlets i don't know if we'll be able to
find that in japan what was your camping
experience like in england
in england i didn't really go much in
england i went around like france mainly
a lot of the time in france though like
it was like campsites like that did you
count with
my family for the most part but then uh
obviously because we're in wales so it's
really easy to just
camp for a weekend um and it was
normally you were just like in a in a
farmer's
land in like some [ __ ] random field
oh like land that someone owns yeah oh
because you could
because they they'd always know someone
you could just be like oh can we camp
and it maybe it'd be like a 10 or a
night
okay because they didn't really want
anything they were just like don't just
leave a mess just clean everything out
because you can't do that in australia
it needs to be in like like a national
reserve no you can actually
you can do whatever you want on the land
so and normally you're right next to
woods and stuff so
yeah obviously there's no power outlets
or anything and you're probably a decent
walk away from the car that you came in
yeah yeah
yeah yeah so yeah it was just good fun
though i mean you just normally just set
up the tent
if you can get a fire going go ahead but
it might be raining a [ __ ] time and you
might have to start drinking beers in
the tent like
if you squished in this tent like how
you guys doing
all right nice someone want to ball the
kettle uh get some pot noodles going
you know uh whatever whatever you do we
did like uh uh duke of edinburgh as well
we did that
oh yeah that was good fun as well yeah
because in japan you can't even like
put a fire on the ground yeah you need
this like fire
because sometimes in some places you'd
clean up after yourself and it was
easier to just bring something that you
could wrap the
like all the ash in right yeah yeah yeah
which is like i think we did that a few
times
because it's just because if you have to
clean it up sometimes it's an absolute
pain in the ass getting rid of all this
ash well because in australia all you
did was just dig a hole
and then once it was once you were done
with the ash you just fill up that hole
again
i mean it's good for the land but i mean
sometimes you can't do that in some
places
yeah i mean it's whatever i just kind of
like it was never more than like two
nights it was always like a night
yeah put the tent up kind of get drunk
yeah eat a lot of bacon in the morning
and baking sandwiches yeah
yeah two nights i feel is like the
optimal camping time yeah i'd say so
two nights is about right it depends
because you need something to do
the second day yeah cause the first
night you you're setting up
you're having a few drinks what do you
do during the whole second day
before you start drinking you can't you
can't immediately get like start
drinking beers at like 11.
i mean that's what we did that's kind of
what we did i mean
i guess but then there's someone like
driving right no i don't know
i mean i i kind of want to do something
i don't know yeah well that's when you
can bring the tv and connect it to the
power outlet yeah
well because it's sorry if you could
who's got the switch with british people
you know and there's like four of you
like a 24 pack sorry smash so much that
a 24 pack won't last like more than a
night that's true
so it's like how much beer are you
bringing along for this thing right you
can't do day drinking
that's like you need like 40 beers at
least for that whole experience
but i mean that's why i like doing
something uh that's why i like
i mean we have we brought like a pack of
cards and like you know that kind of
stuff i mean we never cracked them open
we just left them there for like
decorations i was just having too much
[ __ ] fun with the fire
i was on fire enthusiastic
this is fire burning like 24 7. yeah
well you're twenty four seven it was
bernie for like a good like 14 hours
jesus christ
just because we [ __ ] adventured out
and got all the wood right that's
half that was half the fun like what did
you do the second day when you said you
you slept in the tent the first night
no no no no we didn't we didn't sleep in
the first night because we we got there
like super super early on the second day
um because we
the first day was raining like crazy the
first day we missed the day of camping
so we did what anyone do and just
had a nice day at an onsen yeah and
slept at with a nice roof over our heads
um and then we just went there the
second day and we just basically stayed
there all day yeah we got there like
9 a.m or something yeah like super early
in the morning so it was like a full
full day because i was in like the area
near you and the storm was [ __ ]
brutal oh yeah i mean the storm in tokyo
was brutal as well yeah
i don't know i i was like i was kayaking
and then i was on the
on like the the ocean kayaking and then
the the guy who's with us like oh
there's a storm coming and i was like
yeah i could [ __ ] hear it yeah like
rumbling everywhere yeah and then
suddenly i'm just like kayaking just
chilling you know nice weather and
suddenly
out of nowhere like torrential rain
starts
will not stop it's [ __ ] freezing as
well man yeah it was like
i literally felt like i was at the
shawshank redemption when he's crawling
through the tunnel of [ __ ]
with that like the rain it was like that
bad and i'm like i'm like i feel like
i'm crawling through the [ __ ] trying to
get back to sharks i'm
freezing right now yeah and i'm [ __ ]
like ah
i wish i was camping inside at that
point but it was really good fun
kayaking until that started oh yeah yeah
fun good fun
i haven't been kayaking i've never been
kayaking in the ocean i don't think
i mean i've been kayaking on like rivers
and lakes and stuff like that but i
don't think i've ever been kayaking
it's chilly it seems a lot scarier
something about the ocean just scares me
you know it's
i mean like the the ocean is just scary
right it's it's
very nice like normally a lot of these
things you know unless you own your own
kayak and stuff you can't just go and do
it if you're renting there's normally
always a guide who comes with you
oh yeah yeah make sure you don't [ __ ]
but if it's a lake like [ __ ]
you know whatever because i wasn't like
a group with a bunch of japanese people
and like
one of them just like capsized i'm like
how the [ __ ] did you manage that
well they did on purpose i flipped his
boat and was like in the middle of the
ocean i'm like how the [ __ ] he gonna
get back
in he got back in somehow but my god
that mama's been
freezing yeah yeah and i had like my
phone on me as well i was like i'm not
capsizing
yeah [ __ ] that when you put your phone
on you yeah i was like kayaking trick
in the middle of the [ __ ] ocean yeah
i sent you a picture of the snake
oh that was that was on the ocean i was
on the air so i was like going we were
kicking past like rocks and like see the
whole this
like i was doing this kind of thing
where you could kayak around like rocks
yeah and like uh like you go through
like caves and stuff kayaking
and there was just this like [ __ ]
snake just chilling like some kind of
like
this is like the entrance to death and i
was like [ __ ]
get a quick [ __ ] like 4k pick of them
ripped out my phone and started taking
4k yeah yeah it was good fun
yeah yeah i wish i could cure camping
with you guys well i mean yeah we
definitely want to go but i mean
i still you know you know gun and i
still have all the stuff with us
like we definitely want to do that
you're gonna you're gonna get driving
license now gone
yeah honestly honestly this camping trip
single-handedly convinced me to get a
driving licence because uh we were
just like the drive to this camping to
this campsite was [ __ ] beautiful we
were driving up these mountains the
weather was perfect
dude the moment you leave tokyo the
views get like insane yeah so like it's
like
you always want to drive in japan
because you're like i can't wait see the
views
all of the all of the service stations
are amazing
like the food you can get at the service
stations here are insane really
like when you stop at the service
stations in the uk i don't know about
america
like on like motorways or uh what are
they called in the u.s
highways you know when you stop at them
to break it's like what like mcdonald's
kfc
i don't want to stop when you stop in
japan it's like you can get like
all the services yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you get like ramen curry
sushi all like fresh as [ __ ] and it's
just it's so good and it's like well of
course i want to stop
because i want to get my car the one we
stopped that had like a full-on like
[ __ ] it was like a mall yeah at the
service area and you get really good
[ __ ] food yeah
that's because like sushi ramen all that
that's just fast food here right it's
crazy there's such good quality as well
like
i'm out here there's like a yoshinoya at
the service station yeah yeah it's 10
a.m
i'm gonna have a shanoia beef oh let's
go yeah the one we stopped at had like a
[ __ ] like starbucks and like
yeah like a whole like uh it was it was
like almost like an anime
shop wasn't it that was like oh yeah
yeah they were like there was something
like initial d
merch like you stop you get that fat
meal you grab that coffee you start
playing the music on the car
literally driving with the mount fuji
view clearance day [ __ ] you chris
yeah it's great yeah you can't beat it
because we've got yeah we got an insane
view of it because that's yeah
because that's the thing about japan
right like everything's here everything
here is so aesthetic
i mean like you like like even looking
at mount fuji right you look at mount
fuji and i'm just like man god already
pat himself on the back when he made
that man
like jesus christ like mount fuji
mount fuji like you know you talk about
mount everest or whatever being like the
highest mountains or something
fuji is like the most photogenic
mountain it is the most picturesque
mountain 100
yeah it's like the best spot as well
yeah it's so good man and like
everyone's so nice driving on the
like the expressways and stuff here and
like not the roads like it's so chill
it's pretty hard to find like an [ __ ]
driver in japan yeah everyone's so nice
i was like no no you go ahead
everyone's really nice you know it's
super chill driving it's
it's like driving easy mode and you get
like all the best it's just great
everything's baby mode
so now gone you've got to go through the
hell of getting yeah that's the thing
i do like i didn't have a reason to uh
drive uh or to want to drive
and now i do because then the quicker
you get it as well you can get rid of
those [ __ ]
rookie things that they have on rookie
things yeah like the stickers
yeah it's the first year when you get
your license even though you've driven
in other countries you have to get these
like rookie stickers on your front and
back
it's like a provisional kind of sticker
i don't like it
there's a pain having to remember them
all the time yeah you bring them along
with you you're like oh sorry i gotta
bring my stickers got to put them on
sorry but
i i guess the only thing i remember is
like i am not looking forward to doing
more paperwork
which is uh what i'm going to be doing a
lot of this japan
as you know japan is like the
neverending cesspool of paperwork
get the paper done paperwork done when
it's not stressful
so that when you work that's that's a
that that doesn't happen
because that's a tricky question if
you're if you you got [ __ ] happening
you're busy the last thing you want to
do is lose a day like if you have the
time to lose a day
do it now when you can right like that's
why i did it all of you to assume that
we just have a date
i don't have a date but i had a day
where like it wasn't that bad if i lost
it right
like you know when i eventually move at
the end of the year you know it's gonna
be [ __ ] hell yeah and i'm not gonna
want to lose a day because it's a
[ __ ] game it's gonna be more than a
yeah
it's not about losing a date it's about
losing a day to paperwork like
i i it's it's hard never gonna be good
so just i don't know
i mean it's it's just finding not even
the motivation but just like
i every time i wake up i'm just like
maybe today's the day and today's never
the day
there's like a denny's near the place as
well so you should be fine there's like
a coco's diner yeah
exactly this episode is sponsored by
gamer sups
one word gamers two words
gamer subs four words gamer subs
waifu cups that's right bars
gamer subs is a healthier and more cost
effective alternative to soda or sugary
drinks every waifu cups as you can see
here we and the boys are rocking our
waifu cups it comes with a free sample
of gamer shops that's right here
holding it in god's hand designed to be
the perfect gaming drink it'll help you
stay awake for an anime binge because i
can't stay awake without my gamer subs
injected in my veins and gentlemen
here's the best part
if you guys support us then you never
know we might get our own
flavor of gamer subs down the road hell
yeah let us know what flavor we should
make if we get the chance
as you gentlemen will now see i've added
my gamer subs to my gamer drink and now
the boobs will take the color as i'm
being told um
and it looks delightful the gamer subs
tastes great are much healthier than
energy drinks
only costs 35 cents per serving but
they're going fast what are you waiting
for get your gamer subs come on what are
you waiting for get your waifu cops what
are you doing
come on that's right what are you
waiting for buy some waifu cubs buy some
waifu
shirts and buy some waifu candy at gamer
subs dot com and use code trash taste
the more you buy
the quicker you can get your waifu so
what are you waiting for go get your
gamer subs waifu cups
bars i'll see you guys at the checkout
back to the episode speaking of
leisurely activities uh you guys went
snowboarding
yeah i don't think we talked about that
on the podcast
don't think we have no it was uh i
couldn't go to that one yeah it was my
very first experience snowboarding
how was that it was okay so this this we
obviously we i went before like we
remembered that the reason i wanted to
try out snowboarding was
purely because of sss and snowboard kids
on the
n64 but uh yeah the choice between going
snowboarding and going skiing and i'm
just like
100 snowboarding i want that ssx tricky
though yeah
because everyone told me that it's like
way harder
to start snowboarding like yeah it's
like beginners find it easier to ski but
it's like harder to master yeah whereas
snowboarding
is harder to get into but easier to
master
from what i understand i think that's
true yeah
yeah and i guess like so my first
experience snowboarding was that it was
okay i didn't realize how much i took
for granted
friction in my life okay like i
i i'm so gone how so so
like i remember the first time um so we
got all dressed up i
put on all the kit and everything uh put
on put on the snowboard on like one
shoe or one foot or however like you
lock yourself in yeah
and then so my first mission was to walk
from where i put my snowboard on
to the ski lift yeah i remember trying
to take trying to take my first step
immediately slip and i was like this is
a bit of a challenge in it
wait so you're telling me i'm gonna have
to go down a [ __ ] hill
when i can't even take a single step
because it's the type of movement you
never do otherwise it just seems it just
it's so
unnatural yeah right and um so
i [ __ ] waddle my way over to the ski
lift
did you have your snowboard on or is it
like like you're carrying a snowboard
i had my snowboard on i think you had
the one one boot
begin a ski lift and uh i was with uh
sydney and maelyn
and malin's partner and and
um a good time yeah milan wasn't having
a good time either
um so only one of us knew how to
snowboard and
so only one of us was like showing us
how it was done and melin
melen knows how to ski but this was her
first time trying to snowboard either
right
as well so we we were i at least i had
like a fellow novice
with me right
i'm not the only one and so we waddle
over to this uh ski lift right and so to
go
to go through the gates we have to like
you know scan ourselves in
right and i'd like the problem with
being like having this big snowboard on
you is that once i start like taking a
step
sometimes i don't know how to stop right
so
so there was this [ __ ] kid in front
of me right there was this kid
[ __ ] pro snowboarder like easily goes
through the gate
i like go through the gate take my first
step and i swear to god i always i
almost fall on this kid
yeah i almost took out this [ __ ]
five-year-old in front of me yeah
frankly had it come coming luckily like
luckily mackie just like grabbed me
before like
i fell on this kid i was like god i'm
at this point i hadn't even got onto the
ski lift yeah um
and so that's the first step that's
that's the first step
i was on my way and i was texting how's
it going how's it going like it's it's
hard
yeah it's really hard it's hard
it's really
it's really difficult to full face first
up with skis yeah because you how the
[ __ ] you gonna do that yeah yeah
snowboard is very easy oh yeah
yeah it's almost guaranteed you're gonna
fall face first
okay so i i i what are my my
waddle my way to the ski lift and i've
never obviously this is my first time on
the ski lift i've never like
i don't know what the right technique is
or like how to like
you because you don't think about this
thing right walking
easy one one foot forward next foot
forward it was like it was like i was a
baby trying to figure out how to walk
again
so i'm i'm like it's taking like all of
my mental energy just to figure out how
to stay
on two feet and then i so
the person tells me to like go to this
point here where the ski lift is going
to go and like take you up
and i'm just thinking this is this is
like this is like i
i've never like panicked before trying
to figure out
how to waddle like literally one meter
forward
yeah that was probably a bit mean of him
to make you get on a [ __ ] ski lift
yeah
first thing you should have just gone
like walked up the hill a little bit and
just tried to go down
or at least get on the ski lift holding
your snowboard right
yeah can you do that yeah you can do
that yeah
but clearly no one told you that you
could do that millions husband was like
nah trial by fire
will be the option yeah okay i didn't
yeah i literally didn't know that it
wasn't normally
normally yeah you are supposed to when
you with like beginners on snowboard
what you make them do is you just kind
of make them walk up a hill yeah like a
very
very like not steep hill yeah yeah just
kind of make them like
go down yeah yeah straight like like
horizontal horizontal yeah
perpendicular sorry to the slope uh but
that was very much uh
wow okay mike was like [ __ ] that on the
skillet right now
so i was i was kind of like um i was
kind of like like a [ __ ] animal
looking over the edge being like
okay gotta go gotta go no don't wanna go
okay let's go now
and uh so i'm like i say a waddle um
this was like me for trying to [ __ ]
ice skate over to
to like one meter ahead of me and just
stay still enough
for the ski lift to like lift my butt up
and go up so
managed to do that luckily without
without any big massive incidents but
then comes the next step but then
and how about you get down i was having
a great time i was like okay you know
what
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] slaps look at
this view look at this like
i'm having a great [ __ ] time it's
like being it's like being on a being on
a roller coaster you know when you when
you're growing up you're just enjoying
the view it's peaceful i'm just like
okay i can get into snowboarding
um
this is pretty cool um and then i get
and then i
see um where the exit is and it's it's
it gets closer and closer and then it
slowly dawns on me how do i get off
how do i how do i exit this seat that
i'm currently
sitting on right now and i see
i see the kid in front of me gets off no
problem at all and i'm just like
that looks easy that looks easy i just i
just you know i just use the momentum
that the seat is carrying me through and
i just
slide it just and just slide off right
and i'm just like cool
i'm like i'm like i'm like shadow boxing
right because i'm just
i'm just like visualizing this in my
head i'm just like how hard can this
possibly be right right how hard can
this possibly be like
in the shower i was literally psyching
myself up
and i was just like sure i can do that
like if if a five-year-old kid can do it
then i can do it yeah and so literally
the first thing that happens
is um the the lift
goes up it starts slowing down i'm like
brilliant i'm not i'm not even gonna
need to do this at full speed it's going
at like
naught point we're gonna [ __ ] launch
you off i have no idea right
i i i thought you just had to use the
momentum just
i had no [ __ ] clue but honestly i
think i would have preferred that
because now
i had zero momentum and i'm just like
[ __ ] how do i position my feet right
and by the time i get to the point where
i need to get off i hadn't figured out
how i was gonna do this
so literally the first thing that
happens is i'm i just like i put
both feet down i literally tried
huh horizontal like that yeah like that
so i was just like i was like okay so i
was like first mistake i was i was like
okay what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
put both feet down twist and then put
one of my first
one on on the snowboard and just
slightly
and just breezily just like slide down
yeah
um so that so obviously obviously that
didn't work out right
first what i did was i put first two
feet down
stood up immediate face plan
because there's this thing behind you
that's pushing you forward
yeah you got to like shiv to the side
like this yeah you got to shoot me like
that
and then kind of go down like that you
know it would be nice if
someone was there to teach me how it was
done i would not have done that to you
if i was there have told you how they
have done it but the thing is
here's the thing right we apparently
went on the beginner slope
right yeah and then yeah that was that
that was like there was no way that this
was the [ __ ] beginner slide
and we found out afterwards um on the
second day because me and melin
um we we we weren't having a great time
trying to go down
and apparently we found the next day
that there was a slope that was
dedicated to like people's
first time trying snowboarding right
right no we didn't go on that one we
went
we went on the [ __ ] beginner slope
which was people who had already
been experienced enough to go downhill
right right
so it was me maelyn sydney and marky on
the top of this hill
maki just [ __ ] bolts it down already
yeah right
and screaming at us
really [ __ ] funny you're getting like
legitimately like frustrated
oh my god they were like bad yeah yeah
yeah yeah and my good just get good
like what do you mean just just go down
yeah just go down
just go straight it's not hard
and maki goes down first and tries to
like goad the rest of us into going down
i'm just like you know what guys i'm
just i'm just i'm just i'm gonna go i'm
gonna do a pro gamer move and i'm just
gonna go down
immediately start tumbling [ __ ] down
like i i i must like front flip five
[ __ ] times
and i'm just like ah damn
snow just like in my mind i thought snow
is going to cushion the fall
and i'm just like man this hurts way
more than i thought it was going to do
it does cushion but like 30 yeah yeah
yeah it's
because all of the snow that you're
you're like snowboarding on it's been
like plowed
yeah it's compact it's like jumping off
your bed onto a very flat pillow
yeah it'll cushion you but to what
extent yeah
yeah i'm just like i'm just like i i had
this image in my mind that i was just
like oh it's just like
tumbling it's just like falling on
clouds
and i remember because and because of
that i like
when i first went down i i did not hold
back as well i just like
[ __ ] went as fast as i can not
realizing that jesus christ not
realizing that
i i didn't know how to break
and so and so quickly i kind of before i
before i learned how to break um i
quickly realized that the easiest way to
break was just to fall down
oh yeah i mean that's what they teach
you at first right
it's like to fall down probably there's
a reason why like
when you if you start young particularly
in skiing and snowboarding you're going
to be really [ __ ]
like you're going to be so much better
than somebody learned later on just
because like when you're a kid you're
fearless
yeah exactly yeah kids don't [ __ ]
know danger
like when i was a kid i was i was going
way too fast and i would just go
straight down because i was [ __ ]
stupid
that's what like i was just like this is
fun i love going like a hundred miles
per hour
yeah that's a good idea yeah that's
that's how people die there's no danger
here yeah
holy [ __ ] this hurts yeah i'm not doing
that again
and so melian and sydney see me [ __ ]
tumbling down this hill
and then i look up and making's like all
right your turn now
and they're just like
no i don't think i will and so they
start like getting on their butts
and just like sliding it just like
slowly sliding down and mark is like
no come on guys come on get up just get
good get up there's a slide i have to go
obviously because i learned young and
i was very fortunate very lucky very
privileged to be able to learn
you know how to ski at snowboard at a
young age yeah
the one thing that kind of like i don't
mind doing it because i'd rather go with
my friends than not but like
it does suck have enough weight like 30
40 minutes
you go down a slope takes you 30 seconds
yeah you've got to wait 40 minutes for
your friends to come down
then you're like right let's go on the
beginner one again
[Music]
are literally psyching themselves up on
this hill for like a good
like 40 minutes to an hour right
mainland that they were they were on
this beginner hill like
this which okay
but it was probably like that okay all i
knew was that
i i stood up for a second and i started
going way faster than i was comfortable
with
that was that that was that's called the
hill yeah because
at the ski resort we were at one of the
like the black diamond
one of them was like only 30 degrees oh
that's not even that bad wasn't that
which is like that
so realistic it was probably like five
degrees it was
i mean okay i get it because you could
get a lot you can go pretty fast it it
feels
like especially when you're not used to
that when you can see the bottom it
looks way worse than it is
percent hundred percent come on i don't
know man
well i'll give you the benefit yeah yeah
okay it was the first time for you so
again
the beginning of the hill was like quite
steep but then you got around to the
middle part which is the actual
which i feel was the actual beginner's
slope right because this this hill
obviously wasn't even in like what's
what's what's the word i'm looking for
altitude slow slope angle gradient
gradient that's that's it it wasn't
equal in great
work so like the best part to learn on
this beginner hill was like right
in like the middle of this course where
he went like a
in like around like that like it did
like a loop-de-loop yeah
yeah yeah yeah so the best part to learn
was actually in the in the middle part
which is
how i learned how to like control my
speed and turn yeah and turn
because i i had two like going down this
hill for the first time i had two speeds
it was go and tumble that was the two
speeds that i had so
um so i while waiting for sydney
and naylan when on youtube and stuff
like
i'm looking at some tutorials about how
to show boys
i want to be that guy who like slowly
who like slides past you and i'm just
like what's this guy doing
oh yeah because the the thing about maki
is that he's a good snowboarder but i
don't think he knows how to
explain how to snowboard because i was
asking maki maki what's the right what's
the like
the right technique yeah he's very much
just like i'll just do it just go yeah
it's very much just oh you just go like
this and like this
you know you know that clip of like that
like australian surfer or not australian
but just that stuff who's just like
and it goes
that was kind of like appeared it's so
beautiful
that's that's kind of what i heard when
i when maki was trying to explain to me
how to snowball
oh you just go like this and then you
turn like this and then you control your
speed like this and i'm just like
maki you're just like showing me like
different angles here it means this
means nothing
it sucks because it's like you have to
learn to like put your body in the place
where your body doesn't want to
naturally be
right because you have to put all your
weight in your front foot which means
you're going to be leaning
into the hill which yeah you lean into
it you don't want to do it just
naturally
you don't do that yeah and then you're
going to like throw your body from side
to side with your back leg
yeah it's it's it is a weird move if you
haven't done it before
it feels really unnatural like initially
because it's like and that's why the
first time like after you finish the
next day or you [ __ ] feel that
because you're using all these muscles
you've never used yeah
i i we actually had the snowboard thing
snowboarding trip for like two days but
i could only go one day oh yeah
because the second day you're [ __ ]
right oh i was i i never felt more
[ __ ] in my life
yeah i feel that yeah on this like
beginner slope i don't know which
[ __ ]
sick [ __ ] decided to do this but i was
like that's funny but also
my god on this beginner slope right it's
like this very
narrow kind of like uh like a hill going
down
like winding yeah right and at the
bottom of this this wind
the the exit to it someone had put poles
like a big
x and the and it was open right so you
could go on it but the only way that you
could avoid these polls
was to jump over them in the middle and
or go under them or go under them which
you weren't going to do because yeah the
gap okay so the gap to jump over was
like
this yeah but when you're a beginner or
you even
even if you're like your board is not
coming off the scene yeah it's hard to
get
if you're not experienced doing any kind
of jump on a snowboard yeah lifting your
board up
for considerable amount of time is
unnatural and hard to do yeah it's heavy
yeah
it's like this right so there's no way
you'll get maybe like this right yeah
like this
it was like that off the ground yeah and
so i i was like all right just jump over
it gone
so i i went i jumped over it and my
board like just clipped it a little bit
yeah
and i was like oh [ __ ] turn around god
[ __ ] jumps just [ __ ] jumps
[Applause]
i went with the philosophy of just like
i'm just gonna fall down
and hopefully i'll like learn something
new every time
yeah like there's only so many ways you
can fall down before you figure out a
way to not fall down
right of course um and so i remember
seeing
like i remember seeing these crosses in
the middle of like this course that i
was going down with the corner
i was and i was like i fell down before
and i was like what
what do we do what why do they have
these here what is this yeah what is
this
and they're like i don't know just
[ __ ] jump over it i'll go under it
right
no because like there were two options
you could either like jump over it or
you could like crouch
super slow and like or sleep super low
and just go under it right
it was yeah it's like you couldn't
really crouch yeah yeah
you'd have to like lift them up and stop
it
i don't know i don't know why they were
there no one explained why they were
there
they shouldn't have been there i'm not
really sure i guess someone just forgot
to put it away i think so
it was really weird but i was like sick
free jump test let's do it
so i was like by the time by the time
you encounter going now i was getting i
was getting
confident with myself i was like going a
bit faster than i was before you know
test limit testing myself yeah and just
as i did like this [ __ ] sick turn i
was like
[ __ ] yes it's just amazing yeah yeah i i
i did like i did like i think the first
clean turn
off like my my my trip down front to
like yeah
i like it i heard connor being like oh
dude [ __ ] yeah that was clean
i was like [ __ ] yeah and then i see
i see this x coming up this whole coming
up and i'm just like
all right pro gamer time i'm i'm i'm
gonna attempt to pro gamer move i was
like let me
let me unlock 100 of my brain right now
i saw conor do it and i just had you
yeah i saw kind of do it and i was just
like you know that scene in the matrix
where morpheus just goes back to neo and
she's like
all you need to do is believe
it's the jump test and i'm just like ah
okay morpheus i can do this yeah
like get close immediately like
immediately realize
i've jumped way too late i'm sorry i
just jumped into it yeah
i'm sorry it's not like even jumping
over it i just [ __ ] jumped straight
in
somewhere just be splanted it was so
good
because i was basically i was basically
just following like my face
backwards he must have been so creeped
out just like going backwards
down the slope like this yeah yeah just
checking make sure what he was doing
i should watch him go into it
i got mackie back i took mackie down
like this slope that was
ridiculous yeah i was like oh because
because they all stopped
and meline quit and i was like all right
mackie let's go down
for the record maelyn and sydney quit
because they're weak the first one to
quit
no what melon no it wasn't
william marlene came back the second day
i was like i'm returning guys it's like
lord of the rings so he came back
finally did like one slope i'm done
like she also had the choice to
snowboard or ski yeah right and after
about like
one attempt on going down this beginner
slope on the snowboard she quits
and just tries skiing again and then
quick with she's getting it
because she couldn't do it
skiing is easy right guys she's like i
know how to do it dude
yeah then bailey came back the next day
i was like guys because he only did like
two slopes yeah yeah the first day she
was like i'm going to come back and do
snowboarding again
i'm ready to try it i can do it did like
one thing
and then i gave up but at least she did
try again a second yeah
i did try again the second day actually
because i remember um
so i i went like all out on the first
day right i i like
because i remember i didn't [ __ ] i was
[ __ ] i didn't realize how tired i was
because we
we went down the slope like a bunch of
times i was there
all day yeah took a lot of tumbles on
the first day
and i i was i was so ready for the
second day because i'm just like
by the end of the first day i was just
at the point where i was when i was
getting the hang of it yeah yeah so i
was like [ __ ] yes day two let's go yeah
i opened my eyes on day two
and it was like i felt like i was
[ __ ] got punched by mike tyson or
something like that
right i like i didn't realize that the
thing that hurt the most
was my neck right because you've been
hitting your neck a bunch
yeah yeah because because whiplash yeah
i didn't realize that
whiplash was a thing with when you
tumble that much but
now i know that whiplash is definitely a
thing you should have got a helmet as
well
they didn't oh that's [ __ ] dangerous
jesus christ
they didn't give us helmets i don't
think oh yeah when i saw them without
helmets i was like
this is a terrible idea like i could i
could
i could go a whole day without a helmet
but like if i was doing like hard stuff
i would be very like yeah i would
probably i would i would not go down
like i mean
if i went again because the last time i
went snowboarding was like
[ __ ] like six years ago i would
definitely get a helmet just because
like
my body's not used to it right yeah i
didn't really give [ __ ] i was with these
guys on like like the
green slopes and blue slopes and i was
like yeah [ __ ] that's fine but then
like if i went down like i i
took uh you went down to like a black
diamond well yeah so i took mackie down
to black
i i was like oh okay so everyone
everyone had left and then it was mackie
who's the one calling them a coward and
i was like all right it's time let's go
and just
let's go and do a real one and there's a
double black diamond which i wanted to
do but
to clarify like black diamond is like
the hardest type of course
it's just like double black diamond
which is like the most extreme yeah and
i couldn't convince him to do that
because i think he was like oh no
he's like i'm good but i'm not like that
i was like okay i love how like
something about snowboarding just turns
every guy
into a dude bro you know what i mean
like yeah i can just imagine like when
god did that clean turn and
kind of
when i'm bringing my friends my biggest
worry is that they will
hate it from falling over too much and
they don't want to do it yeah yeah
because then i'm like what
i can't bring my friends again like yeah
i can't go we can't go to the alps you
know we can't go to italy
drink espressos then hit the slopes yeah
have a few bevies in germany and hit the
apps you know they can't do that's what
i want to do
so and then i was like yeah it's just
the boys now it's just me and mackie i'm
gonna take him down to black
and so i meant i found one where that i
he definitely didn't want to do i was
like come on
cost it i'll be fine i'll be fine
knowing monkey he can't say no
yeah he was like ah he's like i wanted
to do a harder song but like not this
hard i'm like i'll be fine
literally like this slope you can't see
the bottom of it like you can't see over
it
until you start going down yeah it's
like that steep yeah and then when i
started going on it i was like oh i
think this is closed
because it hadn't been treated at all it
was like all ice it was all steep ice
like crevices and like it was so steep
that when you would go off a little bit
you would fall and
yeah crevice right nice it was
it took all my [ __ ] energy to get
down this thing without falling over
that's [ __ ] terrifying i was
absolutely
exhausted i don't really get tired when
i go on like blue or red ones because i
don't really have to use that much work
i kind of get crazy but on the really
tough ones the amount you're turning you
have to constantly turn and throw your
body where it doesn't the board is like
no no we can't turn on this it's too
steep yeah yeah
you have to force it otherwise you're
going too fast so i'm like i'm like
knackered
and then i look up and i see maggie just
he gets up [ __ ]
pop like falls over gets up falls over
gets up falls through
i was like oh my god malian's gonna
[ __ ] kill me
yeah really thought i like killed him
she was like oh my god
oh my god connor's gonna kill him yeah
that's gonna cause that was on the
second day right
yeah yeah cause like uh we we went our
separate ways on the second day because
i you know i woke up felt like
everything was aching everything felt
like [ __ ] but
i was just like no i'm i'm i'm a still
guy i'm sorry you're still pumped
i'm just i'm still pumped because i
really really wanted a second day so i
was like oh
easy fight through the pain what it's
just just a bit of muscle ache right you
can get through a bit of muscle ache
so these guys go off to like a
completely different course yeah
yeah there's like two sides of the mouth
yeah that was like two sides of the
mouth so these guys got a completely
different course and i'm just like
great i'll just be left to my own
devices and by the end of this day i'm
going to conquer this beginner hill
right because i i felt like
so uh sydney had given up by then
um and everyone else was on this other
hill and on the second day it was
actually like
almost empty compared to the first day
because the first day was like i think
like
it was like a sunday wasn't it or like a
saturday ah yeah it must have been it
was it was like a public holiday
and the second day wasn't a public
holiday so like the slaves were like
almost empty conditions as well there's
like a [ __ ] ton of snow and it was like
perfectly clear oh no sun was out it was
like perfect yeah it's nice
so i i so i get up to the beginning of
slope on the second day everything
aching as [ __ ] and i'm just like
it's fine all i need to do is like
tumble once and i'll just like
fight through the pain and you know get
it get it over with so like
i go down right uh i go i start going
down this beginning he'll get further
than i
did yesterday because i got more used to
it yeah and then i tumble
and i was like all right i i'm like you
know i expected this
but like i tumbled and i landed with my
head like downhill
so like so like i was i was like
downhill like this yeah
right and um and then i i quickly
realized
oh how do i get up
right because because my neck my neck
muscles
were not working at that point so i i i
could not lift my neck to go
like that i was not only like lift i was
i was lifting it not only
like you know even even when i was like
perfectly flat
it was hard enough to lift my neck up no
i was going against the hill as well to
lift my neck up
so i quickly realized i couldn't lift my
neck up and i quickly realized
how heavy my gear that i was wearing
because
what i would do is just if i'm face down
i just bring my board
i do like a flip you can do a flip but
you can also kind of just like tone your
body around like shimmy
if you want to be faster you can just
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah stamp it into
this yeah
i i i did not have enough ab strength at
that time
that's how much like that's how much
like my everything was aching yeah of
course
this episode of trash taste is sponsored
by manscaped father's day is just around
the corner and you probably need a gift
for a hairy dad
make your dad proud this year and get
him and yourself the manscaped lawner
4.0
you heard that right joey the lawn nerf
4.0 get 20
off plus free shipping with the code
trashtaste manscape.com every time i go
into an onsen here in japan i look
around
at all of these men and think damn
they're hairy as hell
they need some man saved in their life
4.0
lawn mower manscape is the only men's
brand dedicated to below the waste
grooming and just launched their
lawnmower 4.0 their fourth generation
trimmer features a cutting-edge ceramic
blade to reduce grooming accidents
thanks to their advanced
skin safe tm technology the new wireless
charging system uses electromagnetic
induction which helps the battery length
last longer manscape also has the weed
whacker a nose and ear hair trimmer it's
the best nose hair trimmer on the market
and the perfect gift
for your palms hey son i want manscaped
for father's day
thank you very much glad to know dad
that you can get manscaped and you can
get 20
off plus free shipping with the code
trash taste at manscape.com don't forget
that you came from your dad's balls this
is on script everyone
i was the best load my dad ever shot
back to the [ __ ] video i kind of
realized quickly i was in a little bit
of a little bit of a pickle because i
didn't know how i was going to get
up with all this heavy gear so um what i
tried doing
is just like slowly shimming
was like shimmering shimmying like my
body to be like
horizontal or something where i can get
up um that took
for that took ages i must have been
there for like
40 minutes right because no one helped
you no no that's that's that's the point
that's why i was there for like a good
20 minutes and i'd gotten around like
i'd say
about 20 degrees
because if i saw someone upside down i
would go overboard
about so after about uh so after about
uh
20 degrees like someone someone skis
down and says
are you okay do you need any help and
i'm just like
no i'm okay i think i got this
so he goes okay um and he offers me a
hand
and so um i get up and uh
i you know he helps me sit back up um
and so i see i sit back up he goes back
over and i'm like okay i got this
um i try shimmering a bit more slip
like my my body slips a bit and i'm like
back back in my back
right and i never i i'd never
known how it felt to be like you know
you know when you see like a tortoise on
their back
yeah they can't get back up that's
exactly how i felt
and so i find you so after another 20
minutes i finally get to the point where
my
feet is like my feet first down the hill
and i'm just like
[ __ ] this i take off the snowboard and i
walk and i walk the rest of the way down
there i am not going through that
experience again i would do like
whatever it takes to not take the board
off i'm like i would do
honestly that's what that's what i
thought but i'm just like it took me
literally
40 minutes i hate admitting defeat until
yeah there's nothing sadder than just
like
walking down while everyone's just
shooting past you right yeah
it was a it was a depressing but you
have to if you have to do it yeah it's
crazy like everyone
snowboards in japan it's really weird in
europe everyone skis
yeah yeah japan yeah for some reason no
one wears helmets
no no one wears helmets it's scary yeah
it's and like the rental place didn't
even offer it
no that's i it's like it's like an
option you have to ask for
it's nuts and i was like you don't offer
helmets you know
yeah cause i got like the rental pack
which was like apparently like the
all-inclusive pack and they just yeah
clearly not all yeah
you know even like professionals wear
helmets you know what i mean like
exactly but you never know what could
happen right because uh
[ __ ] uh what was it michael
schumacher fell and hit a rock didn't he
and then he's like
he's in a like vegetative state now i
think is he and he's like a really
experienced skier yeah yeah
and he just hit a rock yeah i don't know
i guess i guess no
yeah i guess nobody told me and i i wish
i
turned up and i'm like oh god they don't
have helmets
i mean i mean i i wish i had worn a
helmet so i could go the second day
without
feeling like it would help with your
neck as well because yeah you'd have you
wouldn't be like
i wouldn't be like [ __ ] would it or
would it just be like extra weight on
your hands
oh god because i feel like that extra
like distance you go that the helmet off
like cushions
oh that's true it definitely helps yeah
also though dude skiing
and then being able to get like a fat
ramen or a curry no damn that's good
oh yeah like that onsen you go to after
a full day of snowboarding is the
best [ __ ] feeling yeah it is the best
sleeping onsen in this place was just
like a view of like
it was like an outdoor onset where you
just viewed the
mountains nice i like refurbished it all
as well yeah yeah [ __ ] could feel
like the snow coming down
take me back man take me back no this
old hopefully
i'll i'll be able to join you guys this
year yeah yeah hell yeah
i do i want to ski so god damn much like
seasons i haven't done nearly as much as
i wanted to when i came here yeah
i [ __ ] did again like i haven't gone
snowboarding or skiing in like five
years yeah and it's supposed to be like
some of the best
skiing in the world in japan yeah some
of the slopes i worked on is
[ __ ] insane i would i would just want
an experience where i'm not on my ass
for literally
ninety percent of the day that's that
that would that would be a cool
experience yeah
like also just after you after you're
all like sore you know you all go to the
onsen then you go for the meal and you
get a bunch of beers oh that's so good
yeah yeah after ski beer or snowboarding
it's just like 100
yeah so it's like i feel like how long
did it take you to learn snowboarding
so i always did skiings my my parents uh
took me um
they do like the whole like package
holidays i [ __ ]
i hated uh skiing with because you'd ski
in like groups with like we did like
bulgaria where it's like
dirt cheap to like do it and uh you'd
have been a group of other like families
and i didn't really enjoy it because i
was always like the rebellious kid so i
wanted to do my own thing but
to like go and like follow along and and
so i i i'd say it took me like before i
got like good enough to go on any slope
skiing it's like three weeks
um and then i taught myself how to
snowboard
uh yeah because once you've gotten the
grasp of skiing it's
very easy to kind of because you you're
already used to the laughter
it was still really difficult it's still
hard
it like didn't make sense in my head
like not nothing can prepare you for
just
how snowboarding works because it really
goes against everything your mind
has trained you for i mean especially
the difference between like skiing and
snowboarding right because like
in skiing it's like if you're facing
down the hill then you're gonna go and
if you're not
then you've stopped it's the literal
opposite with snowboarding right
you need to be facing the side to go and
this way you stop
but you know the thing that made me want
to change really badly was that i [ __ ]
i'm sure anyone who skis will know this
the shoes are just
[ __ ] the worst the worst you know and
because because we were concrete blocks
because we were doing because we were
doing like you know i'm really really
grateful that my parents took me on
these like
they were like the cheapest skiing
holidays you could get right so we often
stayed
really really far away from the places
and you have to put your ski shoes on
yeah like you know kind of looks like
kind of look like clown shoes yeah
so you put these shoes on like 10
minutes before you'd like 10 minute walk
from the bus
so you have to walk i'm like 13 with my
skis yeah
i'm not that strong yeah walking ten
minutes with my skis in these horrible
things click clock click and then you
have to wait on the bus for 20 minutes i
need to walk another like five minutes
and it's just like i hated it yeah and
then i was like you know what i hate
these shoes so goddamn much
it's so painful wearing them it's
everything about these suck they
absolutely destroy your anger yes and i
was like i don't care what it takes i'm
gonna learn to snowboard for those god
because you just get boots yeah the
first time i was snowboarding boots i
was like
i can walk normally you know when you're
at the restaurant you know you see these
people with their trays like clocking
yeah
oh don't mind me just getting a beer
i'll take that thank you very much you
know
it's like you just get so much more
freedom and so much chiller like i don't
know
you haven't got poles to carry and so
that's why i wanted to learn it i
[ __ ]
sucked first three days i just kept
falling over oh yeah so yeah me my
little brother did it at the same time
and my little brother sprained his ankle
like first day yeah gave up and i was
like nah i'm determined
i'd say snowboarding the first week that
i did it i was pretty
[ __ ] i could go down a black slope by
the end but i was doing it really badly
i was just
like going like this you know yeah
really slowly but i went down it
um and then i'd say like it took me like
maybe two or three more weeks before i
felt like i could i was actually doing
it good
but yeah self-taught yeah i mean it's
it's just about like
you know just getting your body used to
those weird movements that you're
going fast yeah but also it's just like
just
you just have to commit yeah some of
these like you just have to be like
i know this is not what i'm supposed to
do but i have to do this
yeah and it's it's scary dude like
leaning forward on a hill like
you're not built for that you know your
brain your brain's not built to be like
you know this thing you're going down
fast you gotta lean forward yeah yeah
into the danger i always felt when i'm
skiing when you go fast when you're
skiing i almost feel like
it it's like safer than going slower
like
yeah weirdly yeah it felt safer because
like the way that i don't know how it
worked but when
i was going snowboarding when i started
getting speed it did not feel like
secure at all
it's wobbling and anything that hits the
board underneath you feel it
[ __ ] tell me you're going really fast
it's [ __ ] terrifying yeah
i know if you've tumbled when you're
going like really fast oh my god you're
just [ __ ]
and also and also like tumbling with
just these massive things on your feet
just never it never feels natural you
know it's it's like having two concrete
bricks just like
yeah glued together it's like it's like
the green army yeah
just kind of learn like just kind of
like do this and then yeah hopefully you
feel good just don't don't put your
hands out that's the yeah
part is learning when you fall naturally
you want to put your hands out but
that's how you sprain your uh your
ankles
uh ankles are your wrists you can get
like the wrist guards but they don't
help that much
i mean what i got taught because like i
got taught by like an ex-professional
like snowboarder and he said like when
you fall like you have to fall with your
fists
yeah because if you fall like this just
don't do that he did that and broke both
of his
wrists at the same time so he's like
don't do that
that [ __ ] hurts i can tell you firsthand
i just put my arms like that yeah you
just [ __ ] do this then you're good
yeah
just don't fall straight forward just
just get good why would i fall
literally what i what i found from
snowboarding is that it's literally the
get
good of sports right
like when i started getting used to it
there was nothing that could prepare my
mind
like you know i watch youtube when i
watch the youtube tutorials i tried to
follow what they were saying
but nothing could really prepare me for
just like getting the feel
of the snowboard because it's it's like
you got to shut off a part of your brain
um and relearn like another skill set
yeah when you're like snowboarding and
stuff yeah and also like just where
you're
where you're putting pressure on your
like toes and your like at the exact
point can
can determine so much on how you're
steering you get so much more control
once you realize like okay if i
just have faith if i put pressure here
it'll turn where i want it to
but you kind of gotta like not panic to
learn that yeah panicking is what
[ __ ] you yeah yeah it's good though i
mean you get the chance to go
go but obviously honestly yeah i feel
like it is a very privileged sport
we've been talking about a lot of
privileged activities haven't we like
kayaking and snowboarding
i remember when i was at the ski resort
and um i found my mom
said to tell her that i was like
snowboarding and she was like oh
you rich now are you because
like like they read like to us like to
to me like snowboarding and skiing
has always been like the rich man sport
yeah it's always been like the white
man's floor
that's that's that's how i feel that's
that's how like i was raised
like snowboarding and skiing because you
know when i go on holiday you know i
you know visit back where's the back
home and everything like i go to like a
nice cheap beach or whatever in thailand
or whatever
um snowboarding and skiing like the only
reason i've never gone before was
because there seems to be like
so many steps and so many like so much
equipment that you need
in order just to go down a slope it's
kind of like golfing yeah
i was about to say there's two types of
rich white man sports it's you either go
skiing and snowboarding or you play golf
well i think i saw something i don't
know if this is true or not but i saw
something and it was like
it was like based on like sports or
accidents in general what sense of them
were like white people
and it was like the most the whitest
accident you can have
is is uh on a [ __ ] jet ski it was
like it was like a hundred i can't
remember where it was it was like
it was like 99.5 of accidents on jet
skis for white people
and then the next one was skiing and
snowballing yeah of course like 97.
there's nothing more white i was just
gonna say when you put it like that i'm
like i don't yeah i don't think there is
anything wider than owning a gesture
it is like it's the wisest have you ever
been on a jet ski
no have you thought about going on a jet
ski i like to
that's not going to jet ski i don't know
i don't live in like florida or anything
like that i've been on a jet ski it's
fine as [ __ ] yeah because i mean
in thailand obviously with the beach and
everything there's some services where
you can like rent out jet ski for like
uh half an hour or whatever
um i mean it's basically just a
motorbike on water it says
no i mean it's just it's just a lot of
fun i can see how people get injured on
that though
you go pretty fast and you think that
it's water so it doesn't hurt concrete
yeah exactly
exactly yeah you think that you're
falling off at full speed it doesn't
hurt but it [ __ ] hurts oh yeah
um but it's a lot of [ __ ] fun um i
mean i haven't done much on it i mean
i've only had like
like half an hour on a jet ski on a
beach in thailand once but uh that's
pretty much it i feel like that's all
i'd need i'll be like you know what now
i'm done yeah
i've i've fulfilled the white man
experience yeah yeah
i tell you that this like [ __ ] ski
resort that we stayed at um
it was like its theme like what its
theme was like
it was very like inspired by i guess
like
american american like culture
right that sounds so bizarre a japanese
ski resort
inspired by america it's really weird it
was it was like kind of what i imagine
yeah what kind of what i imagine a ferry
would be like
you know it had a lot of different um
a lot of different things for like 1950s
carnival style i'd say
weird in japan in japan whereabouts did
you guys go
hokkaido oh hokkaido yeah yeah but there
was some areas of this hotel that were
like
totally normal chill but there's a big
area that was like kids theme park yeah
carnival theme it was really weird
so so they had like they had like these
um animatronics
um chuck e cheese [ __ ] yeah like yeah
exactly like that she's like some chucky
cheese [ __ ] right but i don't know
when they had bought these animatronics
i don't know when they had bought these
animatronics because we were just um me
and sydney were just
sitting there like and they'd play these
like songs right
they'd have these like animatronic
concerts like in in this like children's
area where you can buy [ __ ] burgers
and fries it was like an eating area
it's like
it's full on chuck e cheese yeah yeah
yeah basically and these poor employees
had to listen these [ __ ] things sing
all day
yeah and so so me and sydney were just
enjoying like a nice burger and
everything like that
and then this [ __ ] this [ __ ] like
[ __ ] animatronic dog or something
just starts just starts bigging up the
confederacy
yeah yeah yeah and i was just like i
had me in city have to double take to be
like did we just hear that
correctly like what is what is going on
right now
because i walked past them and i was
like don't mind my own thing i'm like
why they're wearing confederate soldier
uniforms oh my god
jesus christ so after we heard that we
took like
a closer look at these animatronics
right to be like what is going on when
did they buy these and where did they
buy these from
and we saw one of the bears was uh
it was very let's say
not very tasteful 1920s like black
cartoon
uh character oh no yes yes
the lips were like massive you know and
and it had the stereotypical cartoon
black man accent of like 1920s
you know like the whole like uh
literally if you go i know if you go and
watch like a disney
cartoon from the 1920s or a black person
with that
like kind of like stereotypical accent
they gave them and character yeah and it
was just that
and it's like it was like oh no oh no oh
no oh no no
why why and uh yeah these
these things you can't make that [ __ ]
these people
these poor japanese tourists or these
these poor japanese toys are just like
ah american culture yeah kids are just
like running around being like
mama what's the confederacy i'm just
like oh yes
yes man it's gonna [ __ ] show it to
joey
nothing weirder than that thing standing
next to a miku
like is that a miku thing
oh no oh no
oh that's oh that is a really good
result though it's very cheap
really good result really good resort
like that fantastic
jesus christ yeah
it is one of those things you're like
this is great what is going on here why
is this a thing
why is this here yeah it's like you know
you have that like your 90 year old aunt
who has that one piece of memorabilia
like auntie you should probably throw
that away probably not talk about that
yeah probably get rid of that yeah
yeah i mean to give it to give them the
benefit of the doubt i don't think that
anyone there knew yeah it's just a case
of they don't know yeah
but it's the matter of like you know
when tourism comes back in right like
oh it's been there for decades well
clearly yeah
you know how has no like tourists come
up and being like
you know what that is right like it's
probably not a good idea
yeah i wanted to think of like you know
because obviously in the past like you
know
five six years it's been a very hot hot
topic yeah yeah yeah
and it's only now where we've really
started to be like we should probably
get rid of all that [ __ ] yeah
yeah not a good idea so i wonder i i i i
wonder though i wonder is that anybody
anyone send them an email letting them
know
hey uh love the animatronics they're
great they're really great
dog is cute but maybe we should kind of
change up the theme a little bit yeah
you know we got
we got a bunch of miku's probably lying
around we've probably resurfaced that
every service
swear off this place i thought it was
you know i'm sure i'm sure you know
it's it's very good there has to be a
reason behind it it was it was a nice
place and i just i
i really did feel like they were just
like ignorant you know what i mean yeah
i mean it it
like it kind of felt like they had just
like brought some memorabilia from
america
they didn't know what they were buying
well i mean this is all right a lot of
the [ __ ] ski resorts are in the
middle of nowhere yeah it's in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere they they have
no idea about anything like that
what's going on it makes sense but it's
still it was just
super [ __ ] weird because you walk
into this really bizarre
you walk into the last thing you expect
to see in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
in japan yeah because we had to like
we had to go on a coach that like lasted
about two
three hours in the middle of [ __ ]
hokkaido yeah right so we were going in
the middle of nowhere
and we walk in and it's just like old
american memorabilia
everywhere it was so [ __ ] bizarre as
well
the hotel part was really fancy as well
it's like the entrance this hotel was
like
marble like pure marble with like
pillars and it's like what the [ __ ] is
it's so fancy you can get you can get a
helicopter from the airport
to the hotel [ __ ] hell yeah yeah yeah
but then i just have this whole thing
that's like
and then also i mean completely
unrelated but i was really offended when
i
i bought a what was it advertised as a
coffee and i paid three dollars for it
yeah it's not the most expensive coffee
but i was like all right fine paid three
dollars for it
literally dead ass saw this woman put a
[ __ ] shitty pod into a machine and
then pri
think coffee i'm like i don't want it
was it was it was it
was a little espresso it was some budget
version of nespresso i was like what is
this you know if it's an espresso maybe
up here not even an espresso you know
that's at the bare minimum if you
charging for a coffee you know i'm not
expecting much
but like if you're gonna put the pod in
[ __ ] in front of me like debt
literally just get the pot in front of
me right in front of my coffee really
really i was i was like i don't wanna
drink this [ __ ] yeah let's get this acid
water out of my face i don't wanna [ __ ]
i don't wanna
i'm kinda showing his privilege clearly
here yeah
if it's to the point where i just can't
like drink the [ __ ] stuff anymore like
instant coffee the thought of drinking
that now
like the the great you know the the one
in the top the less cafe once
yeah oh jesus christ i share my
privilege i don't even care dude
if show my privilege would mean i don't
have to drink that [ __ ] again gladly
look at you not drinking instant coffee
going snowboarding
it's not privileged it's called [ __ ]
taking care of myself putting that
[ __ ]
dog dirt water acid into my body if
you're still drinking instant coffee
i get it if you're desperate i i always
have it in the cupboard if i'm desperate
i have nothing else i'll do it yeah but
if that's your like
can't wait for my morning cup of coffee
put acid in hot water
no don't do that you're worth more than
that don't give these don't enable these
companies to sell this garbage [ __ ]
that they call coffee it's not coffee uh
rant over
there would you drink it would you drink
it i don't drink it i mean
that'll be up here boys what the [ __ ] i
mean you you you kind of you kind of
saying well i'm thinking yeah the stage
is all yours let the white man [ __ ]
yeah
like the white privileged white man who
just came back from snowboarding
it's [ __ ] me where am i gonna
snowboard
oh my god because like the worst part of
like staying in a hotel right
is just knowing that you're gonna have
to like drink that shitty
instant three in one coffee you mean
that shitty coffee that you had at the
ryokan as well
at camping oh god don't remind me so
that's the coffee machine in the door
con right
okay hold up though though the fact that
there's a coffee machine in a ryokan
it's already uh
it's it's okay yeah yeah there's
normally no coffee usually there isn't
right so so all of us when we walked in
we saw that and the guy was like yeah so
for people who are staying you get free
coffee at the coffee machine and
everyone's like
perfect that's great tomorrow morning's
gonna be fantastic
walk up and my first red flag was it was
like
free coffee and i was like no no make me
pay please there is nothing scarier than
something that's fulfilling
because i i i was gonna be like i sleep
that's fine yeah
i was i was like it's a it's a machine
that serves coffee
and you press the button and you could
hear beans grinding so i'm just like
surely surely there must be some quality
to this
if i can hear something whirring in the
machine it's not just a pod or something
like that
so i get this coffee i drink it and i'm
just like man i never thought i would
ask for a refund for a free coffee but
i'm kind of considering it now how is it
so bad though it was like grounded
coffee
beans i mean i don't know if it was
grounded coffee there might have just
been like beans
in a container pretty sure they just
grounded dirt and
they sold it as coffee because that's
pretty sure it was the things that were
being grown about right like from
from the dirt that they don't like some
vacuums have like speakers in them to
to have like sounds play when you pick
up stuff like to make it sound more
it was not fresh coffee um it was it was
a lot of it was beans those beans have
been there since those animatronics
once you uh grind the beans they go bad
like within like uh
oh god i don't know how long maybe like
a few weeks well clearly the people at
the hotel didn't know they're like well
i mean
once they're in the machine they're good
to go aren't they yeah
they they get pretty bad pretty quickly
yeah that's why you're supposed to like
grind them
when you drink them yeah yeah but
clearly they didn't think about that
they were like well there you go
unlimited supply of coffee right here
for you find people staying it out
on this hotel honestly i will happily be
called privileged
for just wanting good coffee i'll take
it i'll take it
because i i remember like the most
acceptable formula i was like i was like
okay
you know i i'm privileged fine i'm not a
peasant though sometimes i'm not a
person you're fine
because like i remember like i've grown
up my entire life on instant coffee like
my my my my childhood was my parents
like drinking
instant coffee with powdered coffee
meats yeah right and that was that was
just that was just my entire life
i remember like after i finished
university you know had my first job
um you know i tried tried getting a
coffee machine for the first time
and i remember the first thing my mom
said my mom dad said to me was like i
don't need a coffee machine we got
[ __ ] nest cafe right here
just as [ __ ] it's it's so easy
i respect myself and i'm not putting
that down in my body so
so one year i buy them for like i think
it was
i can't remember if it was christmas or
one of their birthdays buy them a coffee
machine right
right i'm just like mum dad try this
just just try it just give it a try give
it a go
and now every every like every few weeks
or something they're just like
son we need more pods son
where do we buy the pods it is so much
better
it's like night and day how much better
it
looking forward to that's is i'm looking
forward to to my new place because my
old place
i didn't have enough space for it for a
nespresso machine right so i'm like
[ __ ] the curtains [ __ ] the couches [ __ ]
the beds
nespresso machine that is the first
thing on my list right here
i said this on the live stream bro i
could like i could lose my house and i'm
like can i keep the coffee machine at
least though like
if my house is on fire i'm taking the
nespresso machine you save your gaming
pc or your or your life's work now
i'm grabbing the coffee machine at least
i can watch my house burned down with a
nicer with a nice coffee
with a nice tasting espresso you know
what i mean [ __ ] man
oh my god honestly i i wish we did buy a
uh
bring a coffee machine on camping [ __ ]
the tv yeah i mean that's what the
[ __ ]
power outlet was for right if you got
the power out why would you not bring it
i think that's what the i think that's
what the power of the honestly get into
god's [ __ ] monstrosity of a
generator and bring you an espresso
machine
bring the milk frother too and bring the
milk put it in a mini fridge connect the
beauty fridge
i think as well i could just imagine if
i i like you know i step out of my tent
i'm like oh
and i hear like and i look over at
someone else's camping lot and i see
them with an espresso machine i'd be
like
you [ __ ] 10 000 iq [ __ ]
i hate you so much right now and then he
[ __ ] frosts the milk and i'm like god
damn it guys god i always thought
bringing a tv weak [ __ ]
bring your own espresso machine and milk
frother that's big brain that is
really the big brand the thing about
camping i don't know i don't know why
but like most food you cook on camping
it it tastes good
right it tastes something about the
camping cook yeah
there's something about just cooking
something on an open fire
it just makes it be like your caveman
brain just activates and you just like
this tastes good bacon bacon bacon on
campfire yeah yeah like
any meat on campfire the only thing that
is just never translated
is coffee coffee coffee like camping
coffee
is just like the most okay now literally
the headset meme of the guy ripping it
off yeah
campfire coffee yeah that's because
let's be honest camping
is basically just homeless simulator for
like a few days right
and like i don't know about that
to get speedrun cancelled early what by
the horribles community
no i mean i mean you you're basically
going homeless for a few days in the
middle of the field right
you've got a tent you've got you have a
[ __ ] power outlet name one homeless
person with a power outlet guard
i'm not saying in japan not in japan i'm
just saying normally
like have you seen it like i don't think
hello people just are like you know what
i'm homeless i'm gonna retreat to the
mountains and live
i don't do that that's not what they
[ __ ] do
because they don't have a [ __ ] tent
because they're homeless
oh my god that's skid row i mean this is
this is going a bit off topic
but i mean yeah i'm not i don't know
like i've i've seen some of those people
have tents do they not have tents they
do
yeah they depends where you are though i
mean skid row everyone is a [ __ ] ted
yeah
[Laughter]
exactly
we apologize if any of these jokes are
very tasteless yeah they probably are
they probably are
that's all right but uh no what was i
saying okay
like homeless simulator it was homeless
simulator like
there's there's not there's nothing that
has made me just like
feel more like
you just so you feel grateful i feel
grateful that
i have a real open mind right now i feel
grateful that i have a roof over my head
and then i have a coffee machine
one day in the outdoors
with a power outlet and i'm so grateful
for that
it wasn't the tent it wasn't the power
outlet it was the coffee which was what
i was trying to say
so if you want to feel grateful for your
coffee machine if i said that that would
come off as
ten times more privileged oh come on
you've said something like that before
anyway
five minutes ago that was like that and
so what i i don't care
i i'm tired of pretending to be a
peasant frankly i i'm
you know i it's never what i aim to be i
remember when i was younger i was uh
the moment i realized i was like this
peasant life isn't for me
i i was like 10 years old
we went on a plane somewhere and i was
like why are we already privileged you
get to go on a plane
that's not [ __ ] oh come on it's like
[ __ ] ryan
ryan yeah
it was like a layover or something and
then so this was like uh
it was like it was a flight that was
going to like australia but it stopped
in like where we were going to in
amsterdam so it was like a two-hour
flight
but i remember we were sitting in an
economy and i was like mum why do they
get to go in the really really cool
looking one they get to lie down they
were like oh because that's
really expensive and i was like why
don't you pay for it like
i was like we can't afford it and i'm
like we can't afford it just just
get a good bank account you guys have a
job right and i'm like yeah we kind of
thought it's too expensive i'm like
oh well if you were my kid i would have
slapped you over the head no i was just
asking i was like how much is it i don't
know how much it is you know how does it
work
i'm young as [ __ ] i don't know how much
it costs i have no notion of this before
right
i'm like i'm like well i mean how much
is it
how much why can't you afford it yeah
i'm like what so you're saying you're
telling me that those people over there
have enough money for it nah that's not
right
that's not if they can get it i can get
it [ __ ] that
that was like a mindset that's how i've
always been in life i'm like if someone
else can have it i can have it why can't
i have it
why not why not if they get it why don't
i personally did you did you think like
that as a kid
i don't know i'm i was like in my head i
always thought if someone else could
do it i can do it when i was like 10 all
i thought was like thank you father for
buying me a package
no no i was grateful but i would always
wonder you never wondered why there was
other people who had like or i wanted
but i was like well the fact that we're
not there right now means that
they're different right they're the same
as us they just got lucky
[ __ ] that i'm like but they want you to
believe they want you to believe they
are like 10 000 iq we we earned this
[ __ ] off no they didn't they got [ __ ]
lucky [ __ ] off
you made a few good decisions and that
you made an air conditioning company
good for you
how to get privileged just get lucky
there's a lot of luck involved i mean
there is yeah
it is it is mostly luck 90 percent of
the people in that first class
[ __ ] born into wealth bro it's
[ __ ] that is true not fast the same
rich people giving each other
their kids money i'm like [ __ ] that i
deserve that
why don't i deserve that i'm gonna have
some of that
what's the what's wrong with having that
mindset being like if they can do it why
can't i get it i mean
there's nothing wrong with having that
there's nothing wrong with having that
muscle it's just funny that you were
having that mindset at like
literally yeah like you're just you're
just trying to be a pro gamer from a
young age i always was like i i just
want to like why why why
why why aren't my parents mid-maxing
life right now i just always thought if
someone else could do something always
from young age right if they could do it
i could do it no that's great that's a
great mentality to have
when it's talking about you know like
privilege
because money's like a taboo subject
right you can't say that you want to get
a lot of it not like
i i mean i i just just think that
[ __ ] like everyone wants to have a
lot of money yeah of course that's
it i mean but no one wants to admit that
right people don't want to admit that
they're like that
i mean people are always like if i had
that but they're never like i'm gonna go
for it
because it's embarrassing admitting to
your friends being like i'm gonna be a
millionaire i'm gonna do go for that
[ __ ]
right because that sounds you're like oh
yeah all right all right yeah all right
all right go back to walmart yeah shut
the [ __ ] up you know what i mean it's
like nah dude [ __ ] that let people try
if they wanted man little [ __ ] up
absolutely if you're gonna go bankrupt
do before 30 so you can at least like
fix your [ __ ] you know
like what was that i saw a thing that
was like most people uh have the most
impactful years in your life are like 40
years old
you like the people who do the most the
important things the ceos of the company
all that stuff it's when you're 40. so
just [ __ ] up try and do a bunch of [ __ ]
yeah
exactly honestly go for gold when you're
like 20. why the [ __ ] no take some risks
while you're young
yeah honestly like i what i try to tell
people is like especially those in their
mid-20s because i feel like
everyone hits like their mid-20s or like
23-24 where they realize
oh i'm just going to be working for the
rest of my life
you know and you know everyone gets
their first job you get excited getting
your first job you're like damn
i'm actually getting paid for once i'm
not i'm not a peasant anymore
because wait let's be honest being a
student is what they want that's what
the system wants
exactly being a student is just like man
you've just gotten used to living like a
peasant right
so yes this is normal yeah you're just
like i i remember
like i remember like somewhere in my
mid-20s when i just realized man
how the [ __ ] did i just live off cup
ramen for a good like five years of my
life
that's not normal yeah and i've just
like entered i like internalize that to
be like dude dude
night out versus cup ramen night out any
time
of course got to get your priorities
right but then you realize well
i have a i have a job with a disposable
income i
can have like a decent living and that's
what you would hope that
most people would have if they went
through university if they went
if they got an education um it's a lot
harder now
yeah absolutely like it's it's i've you
know i was
lucky enough to get even my first job
after i
graduated from uni which a lot of people
have a hard time
have a hard time doing now but i will
say if you are able to be in a position
where you can give yourself a safety net
then by all means [ __ ] up in your 20s
[ __ ] because
your 20s are the best point where you
can [ __ ] up in that in life
and still it not be the end of the world
yeah you still have enough time to
recoup right and like you know get back
to ground zero
yeah that's why i was just i was like
[ __ ] it yeah i'll try youtubing it's
probably a terrible idea to
lose two or three years of my possible
long engineering career to this
[ __ ] like i'm gonna try it like why
wouldn't i try it like it'd be so
cool not to try it you know yeah go for
gold but i mean i
i mean it does get to a point where um
because i i mean if i went down like the
engineering path i'm sure you too you
know
eventually in your 40s you'd probably
have a very cushy wage you'd you know
you'd be very
very nice you know you'd be able to
afford very fine things in life when you
get
becoming a chartered engineer the pay
you get is very good yeah
and when you work in certain places
where the engineering gets you know more
difficult or whatever like you can start
getting nutty money yeah yeah
um but i was just like yeah [ __ ] that
i'd rather take 20k yeah doing something
that i like that also has the chance
to make way more down the line you know
and that's what i was always like though
i i always thought why
settle you know i i would rather risk
losing at all
trying to make a million dollars and
then just settle for like
you know comfortable yeah because to me
it's like
you know i i can do that at any point in
my life i i can settle down and and do
things
you know because you never know like
without career right like it could start
happening tomorrow for all we know yeah
like if you
can become the biggest [ __ ] youtuber
on the planet next week dude you're set
for life you know what i mean so it's
like
but i i don't even think of it like that
it's not like
how i see youtube anyway but i just i
just would rather risk and do something
that's
kind of like oh that's kind of could
lose it all he xd
could like just become homeless tomorrow
fine
better start camping right but like i
mean
it's i'd rather try it like yeah of
course
i mean i think it's important to like
recognize that some people are just not
in the position to be able to drive
that's true yeah because that's just
true because like i was very
very lucky that i i'd built up the
savings and i
also had a really good family that set
me up exactly exactly
because like i will say this right now
like my i was never brought up like my
family weren't in the best of financial
positions
at all but like i was lucky enough to
have like a mom and dad who's like
work their [ __ ] asses off to like get
me through and give me
a better opportunity than they ever had
and that's why like right now i'm trying
to like
most of like most of everything i earn i
like i like spend on them i spend more
on them than they do on me because i
feel like
it's my way of like paying back the
opportunity that they gave me yeah yeah
because good boy yeah i mean it's
it's such a good song i mean dude like
yeah i mean my parents like
especially my dad he came up from like
[ __ ] poverty almost in [ __ ]
thailand and
like somehow found found his way to
england and worked his [ __ ] ass off
had a much harder life than i ever went
through so of course i'm like [ __ ]
dead
is that [ __ ] bad ass though like you
know he had a dream move to
england and then his son's like
engineering degree and then now he talks
about titties
that was that part that part of the
story he probably doesn't tell that
his family gatherings but now he's
[ __ ] proud now
he's like yeah like that's badass dude
yeah exactly because because i i feel
like it's
you know it's it's a fallacy where you
you know you think money solves
every problem that you have when money
money does not solve it
it makes life significantly easier yeah
it sounds so pretty privileged when you
say that but like no not like as someone
who you know has been poor in their life
money doesn't solve
every problem but there is a point in
your life where
money is ninety percent of your problems
right right and just
and and once you get your money is your
problem you don't really have time to
think about anything
other than money exactly and like my
mentality when i was a kid was just
i just want to get by and have and be
like comfortable yeah because i'm saying
and you know i i feel like that was that
was my big driving force to like really
try to be successful to take risks is
just because i was just tired of just
not like knowing what my life situation
would be like five years down the line
it's just like how am i
how the [ __ ] am i going to take care of
my parents when they get old like that
that was that was a big [ __ ] thing
for me
there was definitely a time when i was
like 16 to like 18 where i thought
i really love video games i don't really
care what job i get
i just want to be able to play games
after work right that's what i genuinely
i thought i wanted for like yeah yeah
yeah
yeah and then when i went to university
it like very much kicked in i was like
i don't think i can do an eight-hour job
like i think i can't do that i did a
three-month internship to know
that i don't want to do this for the
rest of my life yeah i was like i mean
more proud of people who love that that
line of work i just yeah i was i was
jealous i was
at the time i was so jealous of the
people that loved my course and what we
were doing
because i felt like they were just so op
with school yeah yeah they like got
through it they got all the good
opportunities because they enjoyed it
like i just didn't enjoy it i couldn't
try because i just didn't care
i have so much respect for people who
you know can go to their you know nine
to five job and be like
at the time when i didn't know what the
[ __ ] i was doing i was so jealous i was
like [ __ ] man i wish i knew what the
[ __ ] i was yeah right
you know and i'm sure for every person
like you know i got very lucky and i
found something that i loved and that
luckily makes money somehow my mom just
believes that it did for a very long
time yeah
sometimes i think a lot of parents did
yeah somehow it makes money right and
you know i'm sure for every you know one
of me that got very lucky
there was probably 10 people who never
really found what they liked and just
had to like kind of just be like all
right well i got to get a job
yeah i can't i can't do nothing on my
life yeah exactly that sucks i think one
thing i've realized more as i've grown
older
is that as a kid we were sold this idea
that there's only really one
one way your career path can go right
it's like education
university get a job to do with your
degree and your career progresses from
there and that's like i had this
i had that mentality for like the
longest time of my life and now like the
older i've
got the audio i've gotten the more
people i've met who have had like
the weirdest [ __ ] career paths
yeah we've had a lot of those people on
the podcast i feel like in
the entertainment industry you do meet
the people who kind of are just bouncing
from things to things just trying to
figure out what they want right now
not even enjoy life not even in insane
just like living in japan as well like
like i like meeting like teachers who
have like found opportunities just
randomly
like like sometimes like what i'm trying
to say is that as a kid
i was i you know we got put this
pressure on that
by the time you go to university or by
the time you finish high school
you need to know what you want to do for
the rest of your life i wish they didn't
[ __ ] sell me that long yeah that's
[ __ ]
that is the biggest lie of the [ __ ]
world i
feel especially especially for like
especially when you're young
adults the biggest lie of the [ __ ]
world is thinking that once you start a
career path that you're going to have to
stick on this
for like the majority of your life and
that's such a [ __ ] lie
and like another big lie is thinking
that you need to go to [ __ ]
university or college
to have to have a decent career that's
also a [ __ ] lie there are so many
different career paths um that are
available to you
that is not just higher education
because as an asian i was taught that if
i don't do higher education
i'm a [ __ ] failure if i don't get
that a i fail doesn't it no i'm not
i'm not like i'm not even talking about
being a youtuber because obviously
we we are very lucky to be able to be
youtube absolutely
you know like i'm not even talking about
like oh we're youtubers that's a
different different career path i've
found no i've met like
so many other people who have like just
found random jobs i mean [ __ ] melin
found her [ __ ] job through craigslist
like it is about just trying and looking
and just
yeah at the right place at the right
time and making sure you take every
opportunity that comes your way exactly
i just say yes to everything yeah yeah
and that's why i miss every opportunity
you don't take yeah
yeah you know and if you which is in the
uk which is something that i just did
really didn't enjoy it was like the
culture of you go to work
you go to the pub and that's it like you
never try and do any self-improvement
you never try and like
look for any other opportunities like
looking for another job is like oh wow
what's wrong with you yeah
and like there are so many opportunities
out there for different jobs that you
like never even thought about
until you uh until it's just on your lap
like
have you ever have we ever talked about
kenny before like your friend
no i've talked about kenny what he's
doing oh yeah kenny's my friend who's uh
lives in niigata
yeah he's just he's a crazy guy he's
great i love him he's amazing he's so
funny he's really he's he's a proper out
he is
and uh he's just he's up in negota in
the middle of japan and he's half
japanese half welsh and he's just
a fake priest and like i think i've
spoken before that my friend's a fake
priest
yeah yeah but like he teaches english
and then he's also a fake priest and
that's just what he likes doing but he
also just
doesn't really care about being in one
place for too long he's like i just kind
of go wherever and
that's the one he literally just goes
places and he's like all right what's
going on let's figure out let's try and
get a job here yeah yeah yeah he just
doesn't give a [ __ ] because
i i have a friend who's similar to that
because he's like i i i couldn't do that
like like but he's badass he just turns
up and does what he wants
it's great like and he you know he's
always super happy and super optimistic
and i'm like
[ __ ] are you british are you really like
you grew up in the uk right how are you
this is a japanese side that's king yeah
just turns up he's like yeah what's
going on like you know always is a good
time talks to anyone he meets like it's
just like
yeah i feel people like that are usually
like the most optimistic people in the
playground right because
i have a friend like that who was like
he's an animator for
an anime studio here he he did like that
i made him through like the pop team
epic stuff
but like he also just like goes out he's
just like i'm just gonna go on a road
trip for a month
and just like try and make some money
along the way and just see what happens
yeah and like he he comes back with all
these like insane like stories of just
like
him on the road being like yeah i just
like walked into this like random cafe
got a job for like two days and then got
some money and used that for like fuel
to just like go to the next place i'm
like
that's so [ __ ] cool because yeah i
can never [ __ ] do that
no i could not bring myself to just be
like i don't know where i'm going to be
tomorrow yeah
i couldn't do that i couldn't do that
either i needed like some some like
at least a little bit of a plan i need
some kind of direction yeah yeah i like
planning yeah i like playing i
like that i used to like spreadsheet all
my like spending
in university like a penny and i would
like have like a prediction of like my
spending coming up and
what i was allowed to spend yeah yeah
literally everything in a spreadsheet
and then
and then when i started like my youtube
started giving me some money and in
university i was like oh my god this is
amazing i was like i don't need the
spreadsheet anymore
[ __ ] this why am i why am i like [ __ ]
why am i like spending hours a week
updating this [ __ ] spreadsheet
it doesn't [ __ ] matter anyways i'm
not gonna spend that much yeah [ __ ]
matter
oh my god yeah yeah and like like to go
off what we were saying
i'm not saying like there's no place for
like higher education university or
everything but i'm still glad i went
yeah
i mean i'm so glad i went but what i'm
saying is like
you don't feel the pressure to need to
go just because you don't know what you
want to do with your life
you know that's that's that's the big
thing right because it's it's so it's
such [ __ ]
that by the time you hit 18 it's just
the expectation where it's just like
you need to know what you're doing now
you know you you are now you are
you you your birthday is ticked over you
are now an adult yeah like you you need
to know everything there are 30 year
olds out there
40 year olds who don't know what the
[ __ ] they want to do yeah like founder
mcdonald's is like 40 years old yeah
right
yeah it's like i don't really feel too
bad about it you're like yes
you know like i said earlier like you'll
do the most the most productive years of
your life like 40 years old so as far as
i'm concerned you're just [ __ ] up
until you get to the point where you can
like
actually do [ __ ] yeah exactly it's just
you're just [ __ ] up enough
until you've found out a way to not [ __ ]
up right build the foundation of the
character you want to be you know
yeah you know it all goes back to the
snowboarding right like just tumble a
couple of times until you learn how to
not done well
what a good landing
get good in life well with that amazing
segue thank you joey
let's check out the patrons look at them
wow they're beautiful look at all these
lovely patrons none of these are
peasants none of these are
not all they none of them
none of always are homeless right
hopefully hopefully
hopefully i'm getting out of here before
we get cancelled but hey if you'd like
to support the show then make sure to go
to patreon.comtrashtaste
also follow us on twitter send us your
memes on the subreddit and if you hate
our faces listen to us on spotify where
the [ __ ] did connor go why
before i get cancelled it's too late
connor it's too late it's too late
we're all cancelled all right well
thanks for watching i've been boss man 1
with boss man 2 and no longer here boss
man 3 and we'll see you guys
next episode bye
[Music]
you